so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
what's up guys I'm Thomas dobizola
whatever you want to call me this is the
dope as usual podcast I'm here with my
co-host Marty O'Neill yo what's up guys
Marty O'Neill what's up we're all ants
and Marvel here today what's up what's
up
sorry let's just start it off like that
all right Marty just scared me to death
with that noise right now as we were
starting to redo it because I screamed
all right so here we go guys this is the
dope as usual podcast we're here just to
chill we're here to hang out and if it's
Monday that means it's another podcast
day if it's Tuesday don't worry the live
chat was fun you I mean you did miss out
so if you guys don't know every single
episode if you watch on YouTube we are
in me and Marty are in the live chat
we're in the live chat talking to you
guys I have not seen the episode he has
so he texts me little stuff I go did I
say that oh God okay live chat so if
you're on YouTube go on the live chat
this little box on the side when it says
drastic Graphics dope as usual that's us
we're just sitting there every episode
as much as possible
we haven't missed yet all right we
haven't missed an episode yet so we're
doing really good guys if you didn't
know there's a live chat it's a whole
Community it's like watching in a live
studio audience just from your phone and
everybody's talking to each other it is
awesome so if you're in the live chat
right now thank you for being here thank
you for being early and on time with
that being said if you're on YouTube do
us a favor even if you're on your TV
just press like it's free it helps so
much if you're on Spotify the same thing
you drop comments five star review We
pre hopefully as five star if it's not
just forget that we ever said those
reviews all right don't even review it
help us out it's free guys here we are
um today it is what Friday was Friday
night
I couldn't tell you yeah I know I only
know but when I click my phone on and
off I go oh yeah it's Tuesday okay yeah
yeah it's been it's been pretty hectic
we huddled up with the uh Team milk
earlier there like happy Friday I was
like oh yeah yeah
exactly guys we are officially uh
Malcolm media is 100 taking over our
booking our ads
um we are not moving sets because I know
a lot of people are like September
January all right we're gonna wait to
the end of the quarter start the year
off right so we're gonna be here till
the end of Christmas New Year's we're
gonna end it off really good in this
studio guys I'm excited it's so odd that
it's about 15 left right yeah somewhere
right in there to the end of the year
we're gonna rebuild this thing redo the
art make it look all sick I'm excited
I've been thinking a lot of people yeah
me too I've been thinking about like
oh what's gonna look like I know what
it's gonna look like but like What's it
gonna look like you know what I mean
it's actually kind of good that because
you're I mean about to go on tour so yes
yes I'm about to go on a tour uh meet
and greet tour and people are like what
do you mean go yo people want to come
hang out that's that's what we're doing
so tomorrow's the first one yep
starts off at Ziggy's in Orange County I
think it's Huntington Beach
um since it's California and we can talk
about it in here we don't say it online
on YouTube or anything we're gonna smoke
it up of course if you're over it kind
of goes without saying yeah but the meet
and greet Merc said we didn't smoke at
all oh okay I made it all ages you're
gonna be able to come up say what's up
take a picture I got I got some like
things to autograph for people
and then if you're over 21 just go to
the back with the wristband if you're
not you can still chill but legally we
can't let you in the back I mean I'm not
we're not going to go to jail so you
feel included but we're trying to
include you as much as possible I mean
you're free I won't say everything
there's food there's ever just come hang
out if you're a fan you've got nothing
to do show up that's all I can say just
come hang out that one is tomorrow which
is the 24th
the first we're going to be in Indiana
right outside of Chicago
um we're doing another meet and greet
and then October 30th Manhattan New York
we will be there
um
for another meet and greet we haven't
set the date for Texas yet but right
after that we're going to Texas and I
think December 10th I want to say don't
quote me yet things may change we're
going to Miami and then that closes it
off so it's California Indiana New York
Texas Miami you gotta have Goblin come
down from Miami oh yeah you already told
him he's like yeah I'll be there because
his excuse to go yeah and he's from
Illinois so yeah hopefully to come
through yeah oh [ __ ] yeah he was here
all week but dude so let me say
something oh gee whatever you put in
those joint hurt my chest remember we
thought no it's good I don't know if you
guys watched the episode last week
I had the worst chest congestion yeah
it's real it's been an issue ever since
oh five days straight I've been
unflushed Halloween unflushed OG
killed my nickname on flushed doji oh
man I'm not gonna blame it on him I
haven't been smoking weed at all unless
it's for the podcast so I can just smoke
joints I've been dabbing my ass off all
day every day
I still have like for like two months
right like two months so I went hard
with OG smoked a bunch and woke up
like just dying so um
yeah OG
come on man you're a guest oh you're
poisoning me
um
yeah so that's what happened New York
Miami New York Miami greater Midwest
area Midwest do we know where in Texas
yet we haven't picked the city in Texas
and we don't know the date of Miami
did you see we're going over this with
Sinclair and just the joy in his eyes
when he heard meet and greet tour he's
like you can go on tour just do the mean
grace
there's so much of it and hanging out
yeah it's like it's really not you know
it's not down in the comedy world all
like that I I mean
who who does this it's beautiful though
that you're opening up to all ages
because now everybody can come and say
what's up everyone that's under 18 is
gonna go bro I couldn't come like no you
can come
on the Merced meet and greet really
showed me yeah like oh my God people
underage they are ready to go and why be
excluded it's the podcast yeah yeah I
mean we have it's all ages man we're
chilling so
yeah that's what we made it all ages so
we're trying to figure it out tomorrow
obviously we can smoke it up I'm trying
to figure out Texas I'm trying to figure
out
places that we might get in slight
trouble because we're we're legal what
we have is legal but I don't want to
bring
only like pre-rolls like I'm trying to
get a [ __ ] yeah just be normal yeah
I'm trying to chill so that's that's
what's going on that starts tomorrow
what kind of news did we go over about
the New York City trip earlier today oh
I don't know if you want to talk about
that yeah I mean I think the fans might
want to maybe chime in and let their
thoughts be known about that one
yeah there you go I was waiting for a
sound effect of some kind yeah hold on
hold on hold on hold on yeah it needs it
what time are we at here what is it it's
that eight on the board that's pushing
it hold on okay let's just
yeah let's just be able to whatever cuss
when I say this guys there's a there's a
certain connection that everybody's been
waiting for since before we even film
the first episode it's real it's real
obvious it's in the New York City area
currently
so going back to New York and while
we're in New York Marty and Malcolm
Marty called me and he just said Grant I
go what did you do and he goes can I say
it yeah yeah this [ __ ] is in the worst
all right cool cool so
hopefully by the end of October
Beyond Joey Diaz show and then we're
gonna have a set
malcolmedia is the dopest there we have
a set in Jersey don't worry you can just
have him on the show we'll make it look
like yours like oh my God I love it so
much so yeah I'll be going on Joey Diaz
Joey Diaz is going to be going on ours
I'd be so I know you're not gonna come
out there but it'd be so sick if you
could come out there well we'll see
we'll see what happens this is still all
in the works but they sound they know
how enthusiastic we are about this
[ __ ] Connection in this episode so if
you guys want to see this [ __ ] happen
let it be known go tag him a million and
a half times yeah go do it up uh they
already talking to his guys we're good
we're good to go and uh and in our pitch
kind of back and forth with them today
we did our new episode average so we're
at we just crossed over episode 85 I
believe it was and across all platforms
and this was our goal by a season three
when we set out in season two across all
platforms YouTube audio Spotify 300 000
per episode average lifetime is what
we're looking at oh
while being age restricted no
notifications Indy out here so that was
the goal we just want to yeah well
Sony's trying to kill our mixtape we're
still crushing it basically I'm not
saying Sony come kill me I'm saying like
you know clear black baller yeah
blackballing blacklisting we're still
doing pretty good man I'm excited uh
next week we have Chevy Woods Chevy
Woods um you guys ready I'm your Wiz
Khalifa fan you guys know Taylor gang
stuff you already know what's going on
Chevy Woods my homie DJ episode's gonna
lose his Minds like I'm gonna text him
after like yo your homie's coming on
I didn't I forgot to tell him actually
um so we have Chevy Woods and then right
after that is Jaleel yep and then I
think we're gonna then we'll see shut up
from there yeah then yeah we'll just
shut up because yeah this tour is we
gotta kind of plan around this tour I'm
gonna be gone days and then pieces like
a day and a half two days type thing
it's all gonna be on a weekend
so we're good yeah yeah we don't have to
worry about like missing that oh okay
nice yeah it's all Saturdays yeah we got
the all the branding and the tour
posters and [ __ ] we're working on I love
them I haven't made tour posters in like
over a year love it yeah it's sick it's
just weird me traveling to go say hi
yeah odd but fun super dope to a free
event
yeah yeah it's free that's we didn't
mention that yeah yeah buy nothing the
[ __ ] is free yeah yeah just come say hey
that's it I'm not filming it that's
that's really it
um we just wanted to do it because I did
the meet and greet Merced I told him how
well it went because why don't we just
do one for like the dopest like and
shout out to GB he's had some cool
things yeah oh it's GB you guys he we
had him on the show I did my meet and
greet at his shoe store congratulations
man he just posted that he sold it
to a franchise he sold his shoe store he
sold a company in Merced with less than
a year startup like a startup I know
what like he got out made a startup
sold it did the did the [ __ ] meet and
greet and sold that [ __ ] like perfect
damn awesome I'm so happy I can't wait
to see what he does next I know pretty
cool like it's pretty dope we start
flipping like that it's like okay now
what are you gonna do it's like kind of
like the position you're in it's like
damn now I can kind of dude that's a
Google room like what do I want to do
next time
that's exactly what's going on it's
pretty cool to see it though but yeah
the store uh store the tour starts
tomorrow all right I'm excited I'm
excited I haven't been smoking a lot at
all because oh Jesus
[Music]
yesterday I slept all day I haven't done
that I found out there's a do not
disturb on your phone do you know that
yeah you can silence the messages
do the priority episode
I had no good idea
I've just been waking up 60 times a
night to text people back
it's all that's why I stay up all night
because I'm always awake people waking
me up
so what about is that different than
just silent my phone's never on silent
okay never because something might
happen to Merced or somebody might have
to call me or some emergencies I leave
my phone on you can go through and click
who you want to be able to get through I
didn't know that I am so technologically
just stupid yeah I didn't know now I
slept all the way through the night last
oh my God
that's what I was doing that's what I
did last night you know those nights
where you you fall asleep like six in
the afternoons randomly and you wake up
at nine like is it four in the morning
and then you go back to sleep and then
it's four in the morning I'm done with
sleep this is boring that's what I did
last night I am so bored sleeping
because I can't fall asleep and stay
asleep all I
it's a never-ending site yeah here we
are all right I'm tired that's basically
what I'm gonna say um Rosie's doing a
lot better though she's almost done
she's getting back into it
um what is the recovery been like uh
she's been chilling dude it sucks I've
been hating on Rosie at all
I've been working she can't leave it's
boring hmm
yeah you guys are used to just always
being around each other throughout the
day constantly and it's been like what
like almost two or three weeks now like
three weeks more [ __ ] boring is she
in a lot of pain or is she no no she's
not she's doing a lot better she was
she's only taking Children's Tylenol
she's not taking painkillers
Oh I thought she was on like heavy duty
pains no
she should be but she's not
I don't know man she's on a scissor not
even oh yeah the dopest yeah she's been
drinking a lot of our syrups that are
coming by the way allegedly they're so
so strong oh God
what kind of a legend milligrams are
they coming up I can't even say it I
can't even say it yet not until we dial
it oh okay yeah because there's a
mixture it's not just hhc there's a
mixture of uh CBG cbn's CBS question
marks okay I don't want to give it out
yet because there's some I tried one
because this is good I tried the other
one with a little bit of something it
went
did that to me don't tell anybody yeah
you're gonna be like don't say yeah is
there a thing called thcp
that's a thing all right because when
you said that [ __ ] in the video I
started laughing like
tacp is 33 times stronger than hhc
33. damn is that a new discovery hey
kinda you want to hear something awesome
I
eating samples of The Hash House times
the dopest Edibles we're coming out with
Hash House my friend Hash House the hash
he's putting his rosin liquidating it
but we're liquidizing it or whatever you
want to call it liquidating it no I'm
living as cheap as well and then we're
mixing it with our hhc into gummy form
shipping it legally hash rosin
everywhere
John's dumb
we're sampling everything and I do this
so
he's like they're 15 each you go okay
perfect so I'm hitting on getting them
I'm at like number nine band number ten
like all right cool 150 milligrams I
text Claudia I'm like yo these are so
strong what's going on he's like dude
how many you guys like 18 he goes what
are you doing
you know they're 100 they're 58 a piece
they go 15 he said he goes no 15. oh
that's why I feel so [ __ ] gone you
could how many did you have eight ten of
them it was a sample the new hash rosin
ones okay right gotcha but I've been
smoking and filming all day and I ate
them just like oh samples it's like 15
milligrams yeah I was like no it's 50. I
found out two hours in John's sitting
there red eye I go 15. you sure these
are 15.
you know I'm Gonna Leave the last part
out because it might be I didn't drive
at all uh-huh I'm not ubered got another
Uber to drive my car
they do that just for me
um it was bad it got bad oh but real
quick just a little behind the scenes
story me John my friend Trent we were
like yo let's do a video today where we
don't get like we're not smoking we're
not giving people weed we just go hook
up nice ass people
right yep be like dude there's a budget
just spend it on random
like yo here's 100 bucks full he goes so
sick thank you random stuff right like
we go to the guy that writes your name
on
Venice Beach and he's like 10 bucks man
here's 100 bucks he's just like what
and we just walk off it's just so fun to
see people's faces light up we're not
sitting there filming them 30 yards away
he didn't even see the guy just
listening to us I was like you know that
was fun I like doing this right this
even if we're not filming just like yo
bro of course I mean if
yeah it's just funny it's I don't know
why it's like it's the best way you
could probably spend money and I said
this a long time ago I would love to go
truce drop people money and just run
away and then now there's like people do
that online now like I see that on Tick
Tock go you did it I've said I've always
wanted to do that you guys are crushing
it and I think it's great anyway when to
go we need to go do it and there's a guy
in Santa Monica does these Bubbles as
tall tall as black dude
and we're like you know let's go we saw
him we were taking dabs in the car and
we saw this guy prepping all this stuff
like what is this full doing he's got
buckets and what is he doing like pieces
of metal
maybe he's fishing and then we go to the
pier and he's the guy that makes the
bubbles for all the kids and whatever
I remember he's having a bad day
the guy all but told us get the [ __ ]
away from me I was like we went up like
yo manageable bubbles we weren't with a
camera just me and John we're gonna be
like yo blow a gigantic bubble
can you pull one over me here's a
hundred bucks Mike bro it's a dollar I'm
like yo it's fine here's 100 bucks have
a great [ __ ] day he basically told us
I'm just trying to make money get the
[ __ ] away from me and I was like [ __ ]
I'm giving bro I'm coming up to you
right I don't understand it's just
thinking you're electronic I think he
thought that I was so damn polite it was
so weird
as [ __ ] I ever I've never felt the guy
supposed to have a bubbly personality he
was the first person I tried to give
money to
damn and it just like made me go and he
took it no I didn't give him a [ __ ]
done I walked away oh he's like yeah man
I ain't gonna do the bubbles right now
you know I need a crowd I try to make
money here and I go
all right that's cool like but do you
want to like what's the biggest oh yeah
I can make big bubbles but I'm not doing
them right now and he looks at me and I
like the chocolate let's get the [ __ ]
out of here I was like this guy was
about to make his whole [ __ ] days and
just just for all we wanted is 100
you're not a nice person I'm out of here
damn like
like
oh
this is what you do for a living you
can't be the bitter bubble guy because I
didn't have a child with me like okay
I don't know what he thought maybe he's
having a bad day anyway
um
yeah [ __ ] that guy oh yeah we just went
up along
Venice and Santa Monica just trying to
like drop money on nice ass people and
it was fun did you just have Trent like
tip of the spear or just like talk
that's how you got to do it you gotta
send him out first to just no no he's
the filmer guy he was he was recording
yeah but dude we weren't even doing it
like the hey homeless guy
yeah of course
I told Trails like I I can't do anything
that's dumb or cringy you go over there
you want you walking up on somebody with
a camera like I just want people to have
a good day and if we catch some cool
stuff we catch some cool stuff we don't
we don't I don't care but anyway we did
that all day it was pretty fun and then
um I [ __ ] myself up on those edibles
during the no right after oh [ __ ] yeah I
wasn't trying to make it a smoking video
at all
why is it so
funny I don't know we got to get our oh
they see back cracking ever since we
finished it we fixed it and now it just
doesn't work
probably all clogged with [ __ ] just
smoke residue and resin and [ __ ] all
over you imagine if it was just red and
the Ducks
it's full of Ashes
ah damn it sorry all right here we go
what's up guys just taking a moment to
talk about one of our long time sponsors
and this is Miller Lite before we gonna
do it you guys already know go to
millerlight.com forward slash Yola
that's going to take you to a landing
page that landing page is going to show
you every place near you that delivers
beer to you but if you're already out
and about go any store on planet Earth
that sells beer and they will have
Miller Lite
I've said it many times before guys
Miller Lite is the light beer that
tastes like actual beer not just water
with light flavoring it's September
football just started it's nostalgic to
me knowing that's football Sunday's
coming we can drink beers hang out with
friends I love this time of year reminds
me of hanging out Michael John just
having good times that's the Nostalgia
that certain things bring you back to
and I'm happy and proud that Miller Lite
is our sponsor when it's been around my
whole life for example this Sunday
Packers versus bucks there's already
cold Miller lights here so once again
guys go to millerlight.com forward slash
Yola that's the landing page that goes
to us thank you guys so much that is our
personal landing page that landing page
will show you anybody that delivers your
beer there's 96 calories 3.2 grams of
carbs per can as always guys celebrate
responsibly from the Miller Brewing
company in Milwaukee Wisconsin it's
Miller time
hey what's up guys just want to
introduce one of our brand new sponsors
new to the show this is ship station and
I am super proud and super stoked to say
I have been using ship stations since
I've moved to LA for bush trees every
order everything that is our back end it
doesn't get more organic than this I
actively use this for my business
shipstation literally took the stress
off me and Rosie's brains and just let
us grow it gave us the opportunity to
grow our business and focus on the
things that make our business grow and
not just the back end headaches and this
is the deal we're offering with dope as
usual right now go to shipstation.com
use the promo code dope as usual and you
get 60 day trial free 100 free for 60
days push trees is just one of over a
hundred and thirty thousand companies
that actively use ship station 98 of
anyone that's ever signed up for ship
station stays for life now that says
something busiest seasons are coming up
Black Friday and Christmas so get ready
get prepared so when you go to
shipstation.com there's a little
microphone right there at the top click
it type in dope as usual that's the
promo code 60 days for free guys
remember every time you support the
companies that support us you help the
show grow thank you guys
let's go what do we got here
this is the very last of it hey shavo if
you're if you're watching thank you for
all that weed and I know you said hit me
up next time it's out
but I feel bad I feel weird asking like
yo the jars are empty like
I feel odd so hopefully you're just
watching this
I don't know he told me don't feel weird
just hit me up whenever you're out of
weed and I'll fill it up
upside down
I had I had a dumb idea for a new push
tree shirt while I'm thinking about oh
my God what
dumping them out thought of a shirt what
doob tube riot
it's the doob tube it's the joint they
got on the top hats and they're dancing
and [ __ ]
oh like zoot suit I was like what the
[ __ ] are you talking about
that would have to be a whole scene
that's what I've said like you got the
piano player in the back if you got a
couple dudes a couple joints you got a
lighter on the piano
yeah like that uh scene in life
remember the scene in life no that's
race Boom Boom Room yeah I call him
Satchmo ah Yolo's boom Boomer that's on
the wall I can see it now that just
sounds like a place to do lines
[Music]
even gotta stop doing this sorry sorry
YouTube
um
[ __ ] I'm so sorry what were we who said
got an idea about this yeah that was it
oh okay that was it yeah that was it
edit in the blunts video and you said
dude yo
um did you listen to Freddie Gibbs new
album yeah no I'm on something meaning I
[ __ ] forgot to
about song number two song number one
was hard
I'm on song two I really like the album
artwork you see it yeah I told you about
it yeah oh oh wait I told you about the
back panel I don't know if I saw the
front panel the back panel which one oh
yeah no front one's the only one I saw
with it with like the Energizer Bunny
looking over the [ __ ] Horizon from
space
it was hard dude it's sick
what so what besides that have you been
listening to a lot nothing I haven't
been listening to anything
just been in my car I've noticed
yesterday or two days ago I was just
driving with no music on
so bored without Rosie chilling bro I'm
so bored too I don't want to do [ __ ]
I've had hella people at my house to
help with Rosie she even need help
and I just been like non-stop like just
walking the room you good okay
like it's so boring
so did you see you said you're setting
up a nail salon with your mom yeah
whatever whatever Mom whenever you're
ready
let's start I have so much going on I
need you to just go Thomas here's the
building this is what we should name it
and then let's go
come on let's start it up is she like
that is she like a I mean she already
has her own business right yeah so she's
obviously a self-starter and knows how
to do all that [ __ ] yeah she doesn't do
all that [ __ ] I'm just waiting dude
whatever people are ready I presented
the information let's go
pretty much where I'm I'm just so I'm
just so busy her is her boyfriend
wanting a movie trip yeah yeah yeah I'm
sure has he ever lived here no no he's
from Fresno he's in Fresno oh yeah with
that being said some the other person in
my mom's house Rocco just started
streaming last night on Twitch oh [ __ ]
yeah he's like I have like 20 people in
there It's pretty dope dude I told him
as soon I was like dude you should be
streaming what are you doing
you do all this stuff you know all the
games you know all this stuff you're
funny you're not boring
just training run with it everybody's
like asking for it and [ __ ] like why the
[ __ ] are you playing video games for
once you cross 18 you gotta like you're
gonna be sitting there playing video
games do something with it you got
awesome personality and all this
opportunity you got a stream [ __ ] sorry
100
yep so pretty much that's where we're at
with Raco my mom my mom the nail salon
whenever she's ready to go man I am
ready to go
um what's up with push pizzas
push pizzas oh my dad named your dad
shop that's not even a bad idea no we
want to do a Blaze Pizza just so it's
like
franchise running time I don't it needs
to be a plug and play TurnKey type of
situation oh you're telling me he
doesn't know how to do a startup [ __ ]
restaurant on his own no my dad will my
dad's awesome he'll he'll uh
ah there's a thing I like to say and a
lot of people if you don't understand
you probably get offended
but my dad's Mexican as [ __ ]
and by that mean he will do things the
ghetto s way
does that make sense yes there's memes
out there like do it the Mexican way my
grandpa owns Jack Stands has a Diesels
or a yard of diesels
knows how to lift a car has a [ __ ]
crane thing for for engines one time he
had to get under my car and instead of
using the [ __ ] Jack he started
digging a hole under my tire with a
stick
and as I didn't help he looked at me
like you're gonna help me dig a hole
into your tire
and I'm looking at him with the jack in
my hand like
you're a mechanic
what are you doing to me dude I watched
him dig a hole under the tire so my dad
will do some [ __ ] like that
not in a bad way but like
oh oven's broken
leave the oven there bring a smaller
oven next to it and use that oven for
five years while the oven that's broken
is storage
you guys have a lot of dads like that
yes
like no move that [ __ ] scrub the ground
and then put the new one my dad won't do
that like no it's fine but Dad it's fine
yeah it's fine
it's ghetto is [ __ ] come on that's the
kind of [ __ ] like that
we need multiple metal bowls for mixing
salad don't just clean down every single
[ __ ] order
you know I mean like that's what I mean
that I need them to be like no dad
LeBron James from Blaze donor Blaze
Pizza says that it's just this long
oh is that a known thing LeBron owns
Blaze Pizza yeah I think he's like one
of the franchise owners gotcha like yo
Dad look at look at to see this list
follow it
Dawn not Elmer's rules it's LeBron James
rules just follow around James Rule's
dad that's what I mean I can't be having
a startup I feel like it'll go left so
fast but realistically by this time next
year the three of them between your dad
your ma and Rocco could be in like
completely different situations doing
their own thing on a high level yeah
yeah my dad just done truck driving dude
he's bored with it
yeah that's really it and for everybody
requesting him on as a guest
oh bro I don't know I already do that
dude does he want to do it
I don't know I don't even think I ever
asked him
what do you think he'd say
I don't know
I have no idea
I know my dad so well and I've had like
five hours worth of conversation with
Dad my whole life because he wasn't
there and then after it was like yo you
have so many kids to raise I'm selling
packs
you didn't pay attention to those
[ __ ] I don't need you well pay
attention to them you talk to him about
that whole era are you like yeah he
knows what's up I talk to my dad as if
there was a younger brother that needs
some advice
that's how me and my dad talk I'm like
Dad you need to do this this yeah you're
right man like
I'm glad I could be here for you
[ __ ] wow
I'm a positive role model like you know
what was it don't drink your juice in
South Central way or what was it don't
be a medicine South Central where you're
drinking The Juice in the Hood remember
he's on my dad he's younger than me come
on dammit when you were little babies to
change you remember that that's how I
feel about OG like you're older than me
remember I need to like take your school
man but not for my dad my dad stop doing
it do this and do that
clock and my dad's like [ __ ] 12 15 in
his head he's been working since he was
10.
truck driving is 11.
on his own truck driving 13. like did he
grow up on a farm yeah my grandma live
in the cuts okay oh yeah dude my grandma
grandpa lives in the cuts so how at what
age did he get did he go into the gang
bang lifestyle my Dad tried to gang man
for like three years and my dad was too
nice for it and they I think he just
liked the haircut but it was in like his
20s yeah like 24. my dad started rocking
all red
uh
so they were in Merced but just like out
in the country
well out in the country Mercedes five
minute drive oh gosh small town
um
yeah my dad was like started driving his
own route to like 13. so he never had to
play football he never had to run you
never got to do any of this [ __ ] because
driving his own routes on a semi yeah
yeah it was [ __ ] 80s dude who's gonna
pull over a kid that looks 17.
you're driving a [ __ ] semi Yeah by
himself yeah my uncle honey my uncle
everybody bro I remember I told you I
was driving by myself at [ __ ] six
on the property but like by myself dude
in my dad's blue [ __ ] Dodge that my
grandpa's still oh no he got rid of it
he has a blue one a white one now he had
it till recently
um the first time I ever spun out in a
car was in that I was going like 35 up
the driveway we have gravel and I was
like I
am I trying to go up the driveway and I
started sliding ah I hit the [ __ ] uh
Bob wire fence so it didn't really
damage the car
oh the bed of the the
um bed of the truck was down so it kind
of went between the barbed wire and I
went oh
my grandma came out with
we won't tell your dad about this
just put the car away I'm like
hi Grandma I will but the time that my
grandma wasn't there took my car off a
jump
so maybe parental supervision needs to
be like you're not there
here's my grandma's house here's the
yard here's a little Hill here's all the
Diesels
so if you go fast off this hill you're
gonna hit a [ __ ] jump and I did like
I was going like 30 in my Dodge Intrepid
I was like dude I wonder if I could
and keep going like in the movies nope
you nose dive immediately why because
there's an engine in the front yeah so
you just slam the bottom slam the front
of my
front of my car smash my face in the
windshield I mean into the steering
wheel so violently [ __ ] hard knock
the air out of my chest just slammed on
the brake just so I could not keep
rolling into the Diesels because I
couldn't breathe and I tried to put it
in dirt and park and it went
I like grinded and then it stopped and I
was like I broke my [ __ ] car before I
ever got to drive it like legally
that was so sad
all the electricity in the [ __ ] thing
went on in my
Dash just turned black like all the
things went
there was no more gas mileage
I broke my [ __ ] car and I just
hotboxed it for the next like six months
let's just use it as a hot box I
couldn't drive it wouldn't [ __ ] it out
of gear dude it was like
and then about seven eight months later
I got it tried to go to the store my dad
was gone and it was fine
I drove it like that until I got the
[ __ ] Apollo At Me and Ed's when I was
delivering pizza I delivered peas in
that car what year was the Impala
2006. okay so it was like one of the
police ones with the uh
I remember the like the tail lights on I
had the little circle in the middle yep
yeah
remember because I found the smashed
image of it yeah it was the same same
car that that color champagne color and
the dudes that sold it to me jipped me
totally [ __ ] Mr wormwood uh Matilda's
dad on me I got this car for 11. and I
sold it for a whopping 4 000. that's
what he did to me right outside of the
paper he looks at me goes maybe a
thousand off man I was like oh thanks
dude probably because he felt so bad I
wasn't 18 years old oh okay I had no
credit he goes how much you make and I
wrote it down he goes
that are going to really checks write
down that you make about 1400 more than
that I go
I can do that because
you're gonna say I ain't gonna say
nothing I go oh okay fraud I had no idea
what he was doing to me
then
as I found out that they overcharged me
for the Blue Book like four bands over
they God damn
they were on the news and these fools
are all sprinting away from the car lot
getting [ __ ] raided for [ __ ] fraud
damn Ralph's Auto Sales [ __ ] you how
long after
next year oh damn the next year
now you might have a little lobster or
something that's happened here I
didn't want to get him in trouble but I
was talking to one of my gang members
homes like bro I'll give you like 100
bucks just go smash all the [ __ ]
windows in the building
that's all you gotta do run to the
tracks remember Marie Calendars I'll
pick you up
I'm not gonna go to prison for jail for
vandalism when I'm out in college I'm
like
but
they played me
also I didn't care enough to like
I don't know I just wanted them to go
[ __ ] now I gotta pay five bands like
that's what you
[Laughter]
know what I mean yeah yeah I know they
went to prison instead yeah
it's almost Jesus Christ
I had a dumbass thought about my last
college career
uh what I just realized I was thinking
back about it
I did a whole standard community service
and then quit right after you quit what
School
I didn't made you do community service
yeah for what for getting caught with
the weed there's community service for
school I'm yeah I'm like a [ __ ]
hooker in a church
yeah oh yeah I was thinking back on how
weird it was because they didn't care
that I was like blackout drunk off like
cherry vodka they cared about that I was
lying about this weed
and they're growing the [ __ ] out like I
it was the only time in life ever where
they grilled the [ __ ] up I was lying
about something and they were grilling
me about it and then I got back into the
corner I couldn't get out of it was like
ah [ __ ] I'm like
[Music]
Sprint away
how many times I said run
I've said that so many times if you
don't know what to say and you're gonna
[ __ ] yourself
run away
hold your ass and be like I was about to
[ __ ] my pants I do you want me to [ __ ]
standing next to you
what are they gonna say you're a liar
like do you want to check my ass I'd
rather yeah
that's a good point we're speeding like
officer I'm sorry I'm so sorry I'm gonna
[ __ ] my [ __ ] pants can you please you
might think I'm gonna shoot my pants
it's my dude just go just go just go
guarantee you he goes just go get out of
here nobody wants to come get a ticket
to a guy with a [ __ ] all over him
I don't know I think if I'm the cop I'm
having you [ __ ] your pants like I don't
know it's a fine line every guilty
person one has to go [ __ ] their pants I
feel like
no when you get pulled over for speeding
it right when he comes up like officer I
know I'm speeding I'm gonna [ __ ] my
pants I'm gonna [ __ ] my pants I'm so
[ __ ] sorry can I just take a [ __ ] and
give me a [ __ ] take it he's gonna go
just get out of here slow down
[ __ ] there's the gas station
right there I guarantee you unless he's
a a racist
no other explanation of the human goat
bro I would hate to [ __ ] in my pants on
the highway go hmm I've been watching
videos of like lawyers that get pulled
over the balls it takes the [ __ ]
balls it takes to really record yourself
and sit there and like know your rights
to a group of cops and like they don't
it was funny because this video I'm
thinking about that I watched last night
like the dude was an Uber driver but he
was a I watched it oh you saw that I saw
he has the phone right here and he
doesn't say a word yeah I could just
feel how [ __ ] scared he was even
though he's like I didn't do anything
but that's an interesting point about
Uber drivers like they got to be getting
used for all kinds of [ __ ] [ __ ] like
you think about that I don't know about
it nothing like that but it dawned on me
when he [ __ ] ubered me that hard
drive oh yeah and he was like I don't
know what the [ __ ] he threw under my
seat if you threw it don't pin some [ __ ]
out he's like
oh the the cop was like oh you're an
Uber driver you're a lawyer but you're
out here being a [ __ ] Uber driver
like yeah it's expensive out here yeah
he had his like law shirt on he's like
I've seen this one I work at the
courthouse you have [ __ ] dance like
where you work [ __ ]
uh I saw one last night
the [ __ ] funny as [ __ ] all right I
know you guys seen it ready Marty
if you've seen it leave in the comments
guy and a guy just talking recording
straight at like a CVS or something but
they're just talking because they see
the cops pull up they're one of these I
know my rights dues
girl cop guy cop walks right up to them
on the camera sees the camera
talking to him and the guys just pretend
that those people are invisible
the dudes continue their conversation
like there's no one there at one point
he goes well I think chalupa is the best
and they're talking to each other about
Taco Bell [ __ ] and about nothing and the
cops go
[ __ ] walk away
I think even they were like
oh dude they were they were acting like
this and if cops were talking to us at
us let me see your license uh what are
you doing out here but yeah do the
Builder light like [ __ ] you super saiyan
it was the most funniest [ __ ] I ever saw
I love tick tock tick tock knows knows
what the [ __ ] I just want those funny
things I gotta I gotta get more on there
I don't I don't have it in me I'm so
scared of cops I'm not doing anything
wrong like oh um cops like they're
[ __ ] you know papa there's a lot of
flame throwers right Brothers at law
yeah yeah we met them yeah we met them
right I did a thing with them they try
to get me to do like yo do the law thing
I'm like
look at me like you see this like this
says you're gonna pull me out like I'm
coming out through the window
you know what their thing is like I know
my rights blah blah blah blah I'm not
opening my door
and they say like say the thing say I'm
like bro no
exactly I I mean I love that they know
their rights they know their [ __ ] and
they're preaching good things
I will get my ass beat
and as I'm like all lumped up I'm gonna
put them
oh we're going to jail that's fine I'll
deal with this after yeah I will deal
with this [ __ ] later possibly as soon as
you're an idea come on Jesus Christ I
know people resisting getting pissed I
get it you're unlawfully getting
arrested just [ __ ] do it
because what are you gonna do you're
gonna get a resident and then your ass
beat you might get shot which is so
[ __ ] up like you better just do what
they say that's not what I'm saying I'm
saying if these [ __ ] are
adamant like oh this guy's a brick wall
he's a [ __ ] ignorant bigot I he might
just shoot me let me just yeah gotcha I
was speeding yep yeah like [ __ ] it dude
it's so frustrating it's been so long so
long since I've been in that position
those videos just put me right back in
and that just cringe [ __ ] feeling of
like
this dude kind of playing around with
your life just for the [ __ ] sake of
it like over really over nothing and
you're really like no I'm actually just
a good person out here I've had overall
good experiences I've had bad ones but
I think it's just the
way you approach somebody man I've had
to give off yeah I've had them man I've
had him [ __ ] swarm on me I've I've
had it like you just I hit the side
street behind me in front of me sorry
like all that [ __ ] just on some whoops
sir
are bad I thought you were some other
white child yeah like
God help me with [ __ ] reaching down
for the seat belt trying to put the seat
belt in and you start to get pulled over
I did that stupid [ __ ] once or twice I
reached behind my seat for my [ __ ]
wall at one time and as I reached I went
yep I did that [ __ ] that's why I mean
when you say good experiences I remember
I did that [ __ ] they ripped us out of
the car and said what the [ __ ] were you
reaching for all that I said I'm putting
my seatbelt on had a ball in my pocket
no weed but a bowl and he took it and
ended up letting me go
you know could have got me on the no
seat belt I think you might have just
gave me a ticket buddy back in the day a
bowl they'll take you to jail for like
an empty bowl I take it back if I've
gotten [ __ ] with like seven times
eight times
four of them are shitty so fifty percent
of my experience has been good or if you
mean to be a [ __ ] fifty percent of them
have been bad I like to look at the good
well what percentage was those uh school
please you're not talking about that
[ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] is that the fifty
percent Nelson piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
Utah [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] ignorant [ __ ] update
update you remember the holy [ __ ] you
remember the story where I got extorted
in [ __ ] Utah yeah for the weed and
all that [ __ ] that piece of [ __ ]
couldn't spell uh Hollywood he didn't
remember all that [ __ ] the richest car
ever seen yeah yeah so [ __ ] a regular
SUV
anyway
he paid that fine almost went to [ __ ]
jail almost went to prison if I would
have brought the Tamp back like I was
gonna take it but why last second I
didn't take it I went you know what [ __ ]
it
that whole thing I paid that take that
was five [ __ ] years ago
paid for everything paid for the [ __ ]
substance charge all that [ __ ] paid for
it you're saying like recently I paid
for it in five years ago oh right paid
for it after right after that happened I
paid for it wasn't even driving
went to get my license last month
renewed because you know my birthday
just passed
waited through the DMV line
all that [ __ ] go up do the test do the
[ __ ] exam all the stuff she's like
okay Rick oh
you're living in Utah and I told him
like no she does he have a hold on your
license I went for what she's like
it's a substance charge and I go
are you [ __ ] kidding me I paid that
she goes I don't know I go it's not your
fault you work at the DMV you don't live
in Utah just kidding give me the number
I'll do it
Utah people are so [ __ ] nice on the
phone the DMV lady answered within like
a minute and a half and I told her like
do you usually answer this fast I just
have to ask she goes that is the nicest
thing everybody yells at me say I take
so long so you are so nice like here
like you're the nicest woman I ever
talked to in my life and I told you oh
substance charge oh yeah I got in
trouble and she goes oh yeah whenever
you have a charge there's a state fee
and they don't tell you that
so that's where my license has been on
hold for four years I just have not
gotten [ __ ] pulled over you probably
got fees on top of these I would imagine
a 38 dollars
it's all I had to pay oh okay that's it
all right
you had to stand there all day for that
[ __ ] right no on the phone oh okay cool
I was getting high well I did it
actually
um
but that's the update it came back I
tried to get my license last month and
they told me [ __ ] off
you have a charge and you don't I was
like dude if they make me fly to Utah
I'm gonna be pissed and if they try to
get me to do to pay my ticket I go I'm
not doing that
all right they pay online like why why'd
you even have the option
you want to fly back nah don't be online
anyway five years later they still
[ __ ] with me that's how it goes you
know what I've had I've had two good
experiences with the cops damn it
all the rest have been bad [ __ ] take it
back 85 of my experiences have sucked
dick [ __ ] I was all [ __ ] looking
possible no there's no positive in this
well you never went to jail never went
to prison I mean they never beat you
down so like that's a wins across the
board like oh for sure yeah I'm just
talking about like oh this is why people
hate cops you're a piece of [ __ ] yeah
but I am polite could you imagine if I
wasn't oh my God that's why I see people
getting beat up
that's that's where that comes from I
didn't realize that people were so wild
I remember the first I talked about the
first time I got my car tour apart
when you went to the drug neighborhood
but you were just dropping someone off
no I mean we were like at the beach I
had sipped like a little light wine
cooler maybe at like a wine cooler
something like that I didn't know what
the [ __ ] it was like we I was at this
beach hanging with some [ __ ] kids or
something when I say Beach I mean Lake
Erie like this [ __ ] is not a problem
like Erie like Erie Indiana the show I'm
just kidding like the Dead Sea Lake Area
what do you mean the Dead Sea I know
nothing yeah well Lake Erie couldn't
have life in it for a while because it
was so polluted by the steel factories
allegedly I read that and three eye fish
like The Simpsons [ __ ] like that yeah
just pumping into the water all the
steel plants all that pollution like
down Waterfront Lackawanna is waterfront
property technically but that [ __ ] is
hazardous do not enter we'll [ __ ]
shoot you if you come over here on the
beach yeah up to the lake yeah that's
funny to think about
because all the steel plants used to be
right on the lake let's take all the
[ __ ] out they're all like abandoned and
they [ __ ] catch on fire and [ __ ]
they're like hazardous not to mention
probably haunted as [ __ ] uh but yeah
that's waterfront property technically
but anyway we [ __ ] I drove right into
a [ __ ] uh
police blockade after my first time
right after I got my license I had
sipped half of a [ __ ] not even a
couple sips I never even drank but just
this time I sipped whatever the [ __ ]
girl I was with had or whatever yeah
drove right into the [ __ ] blockade my
boy who was with me had a couple
backpacks full of with bottles
liquor yeah liquor that's why he was he
was drinking I wasn't even I don't even
owe you a drink I [ __ ] sipped
whatever the girl had or whatever uh
he had gotten out I couldn't remember if
he I didn't really know if he took his
[ __ ] out of the trunk or not I dropped
him off turned back around went down the
street bam right into the blockade right
out of the car ripped me out on the hood
all the [ __ ] car all my [ __ ] completely
ripped out ripped the center console off
the [ __ ] thing the whole like what a
[ __ ] it is really really went through my
[ __ ] and gave me a breathalyzer
and they came back they're like
you want any medicine
and I was like
yeah yeah uh for acne
just thinking that and they're like
all right why it must I must have blew a
.000 something
uh how are you
like 16. oh [ __ ] toy your car part a
little kid yeah yeah
that's cool but that was horrifying and
that was a giant wake up then I really
started being super paranoid of them
after that every time I was driving and
I never drink I've never have that's
never been my thing but even just period
like knowing every corner preparing
because it's not like that around here
in Buffalo they set up Roblox all the
[ __ ] people said they do they're like
chicken yeah exactly what text them out
and mass text checkpoint 16th and G yeah
thanks man yeah I don't miss that [ __ ]
just coming home from work going through
them and like
randomly just not like all in your life
I haven't like like I always say I
haven't had I've had zero interaction
with them since I've lived here going on
10 years now minus the bomb scare
incident
you know so they're having faith
yo I never told you here's a story I
just it just hit me
sorry OG
but not sorry
I tell this man yo you drank like three
beers you're not drunk but if you brew
breathalyzer your car is getting towed
you're going to [ __ ] jail
don't worry Brody I'm fine bro see this
joint this makes me not drunk like
you're not even drunk I'm talking about
the breathalyzer [ __ ] three beers is
like I'll get in the car these three
you're fine
any more than that I don't even want me
to drive like if you blow a [ __ ]
breath eyes you're gonna get in trouble
bro like we oh sorry you're drinking
wine drink too glad like glasses of wine
I'm like
that shit's not that you're drunk but if
we get pulled over yeah you got glasses
on at night yeah with a backwards
baseball cap and an M3 like [ __ ]
looks like a little bit suspicious all
right with the glass yeah
or M4 I don't know what car it is this
is M sum
anyway
we're just driving we're driving down
the street this oh sorry we're in this
big ass big cars family car it's like
four years ago
smoked a cube like like a quarter weed
probably not gonna keep you it was
probably a quarter weed we went to the
restaurant
smoke smoke he drank a little like full
chill I think we have a video of it we
put like five joints in this thing we're
smoking like five joints at once anyway
the car was boxed then we left started
driving boom
boom is on on a Sunset and I looked and
go don't turn he was about to turn so
don't turn and I saw two [ __ ] bite
cops on some on people's Lawns waiting
for it I was like don't turn
and he's like oh like hey remember when
I told you you shouldn't be driving you
should let me drive [ __ ] hold on
don't turn like don't try to because if
you try to take a left or a right before
a checkpoint you are getting pulled over
because they think you're evading yeah
you might just be taken left or right
nine times out of ten you got something
in the car oh Jesus right in front of
them there's a three-point turn around
oh man I've seen that go down in Merced
I'm like bro what are you doing oh my
God like come on the worst feeling in
the world
is when I go by the checkpoints and I
see like six people on the curb oh it
feels so bad
not that they're drinking [ __ ] you don't
drink and drive
but what do you know it's like some weed
they got [ __ ] on the car it's like
okay
we [ __ ] you know that feeling like oh
I'm sorry and if it's ever been you in
there and you see the people pass we all
feel for you all right I just let you
know every time I see someone pull over
by a copy called damn [ __ ] that sucks I
hope you're getting anyway we're getting
up
get up
and Mindy OG's wife's right there I'm
behind oh gee so I could see the back of
his head I can see his eyes to the rear
view and I could see the cop I roll my
window down
smiling just to make it look like
yeah we're family here come on he's not
faded there's there's nothing in here
this bag even though it was like a p who
gives a [ __ ]
we're going pull up and OG has no
glasses on because you know like you
can't wear the glasses bro you're gonna
automatic I'll take your [ __ ] glasses
off
and we pull up the guy the officer's
like hey how you doing today
so [ __ ] now he looks at his eyes like
you drink everything to drink tonight
and he goes uh no I had like a glass of
wine at a dinner and told him what
restaurant [ __ ] that restaurants might
even say it [ __ ] you
um damn
another long story wild as [ __ ] [ __ ]
them
and he's like you know smells real real
heavy in here and I'm like
what do you want me to say but I can see
OG like oh man yeah sorry yeah we smoked
earlier man sorry like we just went to
dinner he's like
damn breathalyzer around now you're
gonna be good he goes yeah he looks at
me goes
get out of here man shut the [ __ ] up
there's no the long
ah get out of here I was like shut up no
[ __ ] way did you let us OG was doing
Jedi on Minecraft he was doing something
to him he did something something was
going on not even done
hey stop drinking stop stop [ __ ]
I won't tell stories on the line
like last year he would drop me off at
my house and he had did the same thing
I'm like full you're not shit-faced I
you think I can't drive like you can
drive but remember how you got pulled
over like it could happen again [ __ ]
we're on we're on the five dude we're on
the five we're on the freeway
in the morning would you smashing oh
yeah and we're smoking what happened
just roll the window down right now if
you're in California and the cop says it
smells like weed
unless they see smoke they cannot tell
you to get the [ __ ] out the car weed by
prop 64 is no longer
cause probable cause to search your
[ __ ] car if a cop says it smells like
we go cool California is legal does it
matter that's a new [ __ ] right 2018. so
everyone out there they don't have any
[ __ ] rights that they say I smell
marijuana
so might be you
um it's California man yeah they run out
of their way prop 64 is no longer's
probable cause remember that is no
longer a probable cause of such a car
[ __ ] you and shout out to all the
workers that can't get [ __ ] fired for
that [ __ ] now yeah I saw that what what
kind of workers again
I think it's just California city
workers right I have no idea I saw that
Gavin Newsom did something right [ __ ]
jerk so
we're on the five right before my my old
apartment the one where I met you at
right before that apartment
we're about to get off and bloop gets
blurped I'm like full no [ __ ] way and
as OG's talk as we're getting pulled
over I'm like
I don't want to say this but this might
be the one man like this is a bad one
you drank a lot [ __ ]
same position I'm in the back seat
Minnie's right there everything same
position
all right roll the window down I do the
whole hi I roll the windows down so I
don't get shot also
um I'm in the back seat same car wow
same car we were in the first time
you're in the back seat and you roll the
windows down that's that might get you
know before they even get up there I
have them down so when they walk up they
see me okay so there's Rosie there's
Mindy OG there's no one else in this car
[ __ ] yeah roll your windows down
yeah I put my elbow out like this I put
my arm out like that now is it a good is
it a smart idea or while they're walking
up never don't even [ __ ] move while
walking up if they're in their car still
I roll all my windows down the second
they get there
now what about how do you feel about
recording them busting out the phone or
go like I'm not pushing it bro I'm not
gonna record everybody I'm good unless
it's getting weird it's almost a good
idea to go live or some [ __ ] yeah I put
my phone on the dash and my keys I take
them off and put them right in the
[ __ ] Dash that's how I get every time
I got pulled I go
hi because when they go they go oh I
[ __ ] with this fool like he knows like
don't make me feel threatened if you're
a cop and you're walking up to five cars
a day one of them might blast you yeah
so I understand why they're like how you
doing I would be I would be [ __ ]
terrified walking away horrible dude
every car I think about that sometimes
that's why I never get upset when
they're like yo what's up man I'm like
I would do the same [ __ ] bro so I
understand that's why I just go hi
officer I do this a lot how are you
doing you're always supposed to show
both sides your hands and [ __ ]
um little guns my stepdad taught me that
yeah he had a little pistol like this
and you can literally just pop somebody
with it it's like that big a little one
shooter 22. okay and kill somebody or
really hurt him with a 22 you know
enough to shoot him in the eyes they
freak out anyway
um we get pulled over cop comes up it
reeks bad OG's been drinking more than
the last time the cop looks at him he's
like you've been drinking man I can
smell it on you like so Hellman she had
a drink officers came from uh blah blah
restaurant [ __ ] the same restaurant
even restaurant damn I I I don't I don't
even know if he wants me to talk about
OG so we'll just leave it alone but
he's like smells in here man I know it's
legal but you know you can't be smoking
and driving like that how long are these
two incidents apart from each other a
year and a half two years
he looks at OG he's like
you see you're intoxicated dude
like I know you've been smoking your
eyes are bloodshot I could see you he's
like you got kids
he goes yeah I got kids yeah
he asked him he goes would they be
disappointed in you right now oh [ __ ] am
I in the back like that
like
get him officer I've been telling his
ass too but I wasn't gonna do that but I
was like I've been hell
he's not like OG drinks and drives but
if you have a glass of wine or two like
and he looks you picked up his eyes get
all glossy he just looks like that but
it's not it's always like you could went
to a DUI for a .08 that's sucks
I don't want to put that out there like
he's a drunk driver not at all
responsible but when we go to dinner
he's like I'll drive a glass of wine or
two but let's wait 30 minutes and leave
so just in case you could pull over yeah
we're good yeah I always tell them he's
like no for birdie we can't drive
[ __ ] tenths of a decimal yes
so he's like would they be disappointed
in you right now he looks at him and he
goes yeah officer I mean yeah they would
I would not drive he's like would you
drive with your kids like this you think
you would you're like what if somebody
else's kids on the run you hit them he
gave him the [ __ ] dirty goes
I want you to go home and I want you to
tell your [ __ ] kids I let you go I
don't want to let you know and I want
you to tell them that I let you go so
you can go home that was his chance to
be like I got my mijo right now
oh that's your son I'm like no I'm not
really his son and then it would have
been a whole nother thing he's very
disappointed
I am disappointed dad I should have said
that
he let us go and I laughed from the
freeway all the way to my parking garage
it's like half a mile away I was cackle
laughing Mindy laughed too and Rosie
would just dying like he got scolded by
this young ass Mexican officer oh [ __ ]
young like 25 year old Mexican officer
like Buffet telling about his kids and
show your kids would they be
disappointed in you right now drinking
and driving so I want you to go home and
tell him I let you go but I only let you
go so you could think about it you said
all that [ __ ]
sitting there
hey he hasn't he has to take it because
he's let him go yes there's a granny
respond yeah
yeah I won't do this again oh dude this
is the best thing
like I've been telling your stupid ass
stop [ __ ] driving it's a .08 that's
jail like 0.09 you're [ __ ]
but that was OG story yeah I just put
them all back responsibly
Miller Brewing Company Miller Brewing
Company Milwaukee Wisconsin only 96
calories 2.2 grams of carbs per can
wow
what was that [ __ ] Wade's world it's
just really sad people just like start
doing ads [ __ ] you it's a free show
dick but uh that's what happened and
yeah shout out to Miller Lite because
what's up renew contract weeks
I won't say anything
but
that shits are getting renewed yeah
we'll leave it at that thank you guys
for all the support across the board
we've got lots of new sponsors coming in
but I'm only light
what the [ __ ] Joe uh Joe Pesci hold on
one thing yeah that's what I was trying
but I kept trying to call him JoJo Volta
please
if I had a gold tooth oh no OG needs a
gold tooth like no he would look way too
way too suspicious bro I told you
executive gold tooth went on him he
would he would start doing this
yeah one of these guys
I was so full I don't trust you I think
he looked [ __ ] sick
painting of him with the grill oh that'd
be sick I like your edit you did when I
was put OG's pinky ring on and you
popped clothes on
I'm never will
win
the first awesome that was a little
Easter eggs
out there that was so funny dude holy
holy [ __ ] looks all looks off
that's great yeah I don't remember what
we've been talking about what are we at
how long we've been here I don't [ __ ]
know an hour and 15 about an hour about
an hour yeah well there we are oh all
right good we're going good yeah so uh
don't drink and drive
oh don't drink and drive I'm [ __ ]
terrified of that [ __ ] I don't know I
grew up an alcoholic style culture where
the police are all up in your life so
it's like astonishing to me when people
even [ __ ] risk it like that we've had
people drop I told you about the Skyway
going in from Oklahoma downtown this
like giant Bridge super unless somebody
go off it going the wrong way up it
multiple times I heard about that [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] scary you're just driving
on this bridge and now there's a [ __ ]
car coming at you and you gotta either
go off the bridge or into the car
no thank you
so you know what I do I do cruising USA
double tap the gas and I jump them oh
[ __ ] I didn't think about that yeah
that's what you do if you ever get a
hundred percent you can just spin around
them there you go family and you turn
into Vin Diesel and you [ __ ] e-break
out of it
talking about
we've done more car accidents we
cruising USA double tap gas here I love
that oh and also while I'm speaking of
the Town kind of
41-7 [ __ ] Monday night goddamn
[ __ ] Victory and all crushing
this Dolphins game is gonna have passed
by then but I'm still feeling the
[ __ ] these first two April went to
both games by the way so Marty went to
Monday Night Football yes right first
time ever right but yeah and then I saw
the bills haven't won the Monday Night
Football game since
1990 something I almost cracked a
[ __ ] tear at this last game crushing
yeah when they had Jim Kelly oh yeah
I wore that that shirt I was wearing
that that was a Jim Kelly
but the thing about Jim Kelly is he's
been battling like bro he's always sick
like cancer oh every day that makes it
for the past like 20 years damn like it
was horrible like at the end of his
career his son went through a very
public like his baby son had a rare
disease form of cancer or something
Hunter's hope I remember it was a big
thing like everybody knew about it and
then he got killed like cancer and like
it seeing him he's looked different ever
since and it's like sad dude like it
reminds me of my dad watching Jim Kelly
like bro you were such a warrior to me
growing up you were the [ __ ] like and
just to see his feel like you've been
battling for so long well it makes
perfect sense when I saw him go you look
withered but I saw it in his eyes when
he was like when he was talking to the
fans Bill's being all [ __ ] sick now
bad choice of words Bill's being all
like looking like Champions and [ __ ] to
see it in his eyes I saw that [ __ ] like
reminded me being six years old watching
them out there in those four Super Bowls
again that dude is still in there he's
still a [ __ ] like champ in there he
never got his Super Bowl
he went four on the road he's been
battling cancer ever since lost his son
all this other [ __ ] [ __ ] Marvel
leave you came out
our Old Coach throughout that whole run
had Bruce Smith behind him these are all
the Legends for me growing up no [ __ ] he
was standing there behind him like a
bodyguard Marv Levy looking like he's
you know God knows how old Martin he was
like a hundred he seemed like he was 100
when I was a kid oh the old
coach you know what I mean like see him
out there talking to the fans
he said his [ __ ] like where would you
rather be than right here right now
and all the [ __ ] fans went crazy and
[ __ ] and that [ __ ] damn I damn near
cracked a tears seeing
just seeing him being alive out here to
witness this greatness that we got going
on right now
[ __ ] awesome I'm proud of that chat
you know you should be what I'm not
proud of
Brett Favre's actions yeah I forgot
about that [ __ ] you want to get up let's
go
your child and hero been doing this week
nothing just like expiring the whole
country what's mine been doing stealing
from poor kids
brat we're coming for you bro I'm sorry
here's how it's coming I no longer want
you on the show Brett Favre
Mississippi that's us
in the back and I'm gonna call it boy
when I do it I'm just kidding I'm not
threatening anybody I'm just completely
kidding YouTube in case they thought
that was a threat I was talking about
like verbally like oh I'm about to let
it go verbal lashing I hope Brett Favre
is not like a key word that gets his age
restricted immediately it could be it
could be like that he might be it could
you're gonna do the breath fire with
that cop did the [ __ ] OG
yep I'm about to scold you back kids
think about you [ __ ] doing this [ __ ]
Brett Favre probably bad kids we're
gonna start with your situation with
them then we're gonna get into all this
other [ __ ] ready
20 years for 20 years it's been on my
brain when you diss the [ __ ] out of me
in the rain
oh hold on
yeah dissed me in the rain that's him
coming out of the hallway
on Percocets
numb as [ __ ]
are you ready Brett fav diss me you guys
know that dissed me real hard I broke my
heart still a couple statues of him in
my toy chest anyway
um
Brett Favre I heard about this four
months ago he did this thing with Ted
DiBiase The Million Dollar Man from WWE
oh I don't know about this they did it
together if you don't know what's going
on the Brett Favre situation let me talk
to this camera real quick Brett Favre
Hall of Famer quarterback America's
breakfast America's Brett Favre Brett
Brett all right from There's Something
About Mary
the All-American man that she loved all
right by the way in in that movie
I'm a Packers fan I'm in the theater
with my grandma my grandpa one of the
rare movies we went to go watch together
I'm in the theater
Brett Favre walks on on camera Marty I
damn near jumped through the roof
like I'm a Brett Favre fanatic and for
them to bring out Brett Favre I can't
remember him being in that movie at the
end when he's all I found Brent and he
goes hey Mary I'm in town to play the
Dolphins dumbass his Hank Hill ass
personality he's had killed if he was a
person oh [ __ ] I didn't realize that's
Brett Favre and then I lost my [ __ ] I
lost my [ __ ] mind when Brett Favre
showed up in the movie I'm watching I
lost my I mean I [ __ ] love him and
then she dumps him because I'm a Niner
fan and my grandpa looked at me and I go
[ __ ] this movie [ __ ] this movie this
whole movie sucks anyway
I love Brett Favre you know Brett Favre
did this past couple months
he embezzled money
where did he invest the money from
Mississippi welfare fund what does that
go to
poor kids
orphans kids without means you do to
them kids brat he's been harming kids
this whole time I'm gonna hurt my
feelings then he heard a whole state of
kids feelings he embezzled or was it
five mil or four mil
I want to say it was four
he embezzled millions and millions of
dollars from the welfare fund of
Mississippi allegedly
to do what
do you know what it was Marty
do you know what he's spent it on you
know what he spent it on
a new volleyball
a new volleyball building for the
University that his daughter plays
volleyball
I didn't know that she ain't gonna be a
Hall of Famer Brad you're putting your
life on the line for your daughter's
hobby you're crazy and that's why your
accuracy sucked because your accuracy
and life is not on point Forbes says it
was a little more than eight mil
God our friends at Forbes friends over
at Forbes what up buddy former Green Bay
Packer quarterback Hall of Famer has
been accused of special access to former
Mississippi oh he stole some money all
right let's just say that he stole some
[ __ ] money and how come he is
not on ESPN getting dragged through the
mud like they did Michael Vick yes
Michael Vick was doing way more worse
things but where is it at on ESPN Forbes
should call Brett fire of the biggest uh
painkiller influencer in the world
probably I like that
painkiller influencer in the world
big Pharma
big Farva that's why you're a rapper
that's why you're rewards Smith
oh I hate you so much that was great
all right let's try one of these little
jaints oh
um so yeah that's in the news
um Brett Favre if you're out here
[ __ ] up man it's okay
on the show ah let me talk about this
[ __ ] I don't
no
My Heroes all over my hero
it sucks that was just you Adam Sandler
come smoke joints with us
I'm [ __ ] over Brett Favre dude I feel
so bad but it's like
what a douchebag
so I mean yeah I'll joke aside it sounds
like that's Crossing into actually like
really being a piece of [ __ ] territory
that's an actual villain an actual
villain
if this all comes down forever is
innocent please come on the show if
you're guilty I know people like you'll
be fuse it'd be the biggest [ __ ] I don't
care about views my morals I don't want
this man on the show
I love love love love Afroman
people ask him to come on the show all
the time
but I watched him punch that girl on
stage so violently hard made me never
want to have Afroman on the show
there's a video of him cracking a girl
so violently hard on stage sees that
she's on the ground sees the girl goes
back to playing guitar
I mean I love Afro man I saw him one
time in a Cannabis Cup like shut the
[ __ ]
I lost my mom and I was filming so I
couldn't stop like I'm an Afroman fan I
love that fool
I know people people change whatever
this [ __ ] was like two years ago so did
that phone man have anything else
besides the Because I Got High was he
like a legit artist Palmdale
okay I don't know about that shot
someone I just thought of Bobby Sparks
for some reason that was that same era I
was bark I bet he has like I bet if I
look on Instagram Bubba spire's got some
whole [ __ ] he's doing something [ __ ]
going on his new trend or something but
yeah I love Afroman but after seeing
that it's like but then again
that beat the [ __ ] out of my mom for
years I still say hi to him and chill
with him yeah so it's like all right how
do I like go around this without being a
hypocrite it's I think it's just up to
us at the end of the day how we feel
about it because it's like we can have
criminals on the show and people that we
know that have done that to horrible
things we can have people that we know
that haven't been arrested for [ __ ] but
we just know they're creeps and we'll
never let them on the [ __ ] show 100
so it's just kind of like our creep
detector I think is the real judge would
I leave you around my sisters or your
kids
no
I'm not leaving my kid around [ __ ]
some of our guests but
everybody we've had here I I don't feel
weird about everyone I've had here
being on ago yeah I think that guy's a
[ __ ] creep bro I'm good like I'm good
like no thank you yeah everyone out on
the show I don't feel weird about
just because they're all drug dealers
and gang bangers damn fine
yeah yeah if they were like pretty much
this way if I was like yo you can come
over
in here I feel I feel okay yeah yeah
yeah yeah I feel you yeah but nah nah
Larry Lawton hang out with my my little
brother yeah yeah smoke a cigar with him
he's gonna be like I love that fool yeah
yeah I just talked to him recently he
wants um one of his friends to come on
the show his friend I guess it's like a
Netflix special about him where he was
like a race car driver that started
selling Mass amounts of weed and went to
prison for it then my cousin William a
couple days ago hits me up tells me
about this old race car driver he used
to watch that went to prison for all the
sales same dude damn at least you should
have him on the show go wow I just
talked to that guy about having him come
on the show imagine being high as [ __ ]
driving a race car oh no thanks no thank
you
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
damn that might be cool let us know if
you guys want that [ __ ] there's so many
if you're in the chat right now or
you're watching this doesn't matter what
time drop it in the in the chat who do
you want to see go in the comments who
do you want to see we have what a 210
220 person list that is actively being
[ __ ] hit up right I don't even want
to talk about the things that you talked
about because
we got a team now guys yeah we're
getting there so this is the very
beginning but we're starting to have a
team it's weird it's definitely odd
shout out to everybody that we've worked
with one thing about me and Thomas is
anybody that we've ever crossed paths
with ask them about us they're going to
give you a raving review about how nice
we are and how easy we are to [ __ ]
work with always we had to let go of our
booking agent
and he thanked us remember you texted me
he's like you know you're good well
[ __ ] thank you after you had to
let him go every person we've ever had
to part ways with us thank God thank you
guys man this has been great like
yeah no one's ever been like well
well [ __ ] you guys no it's always been
like yeah that's just levels levels like
I get it you guys can't you guys need
more yeah that's just the way it is yeah
but it's really nice to have a team of
like 10 people that are just on it and
just have tight communication and they
care and they're fired up and they're
enthusiastic and they love it like this
is exciting for everybody I feel that
you want that from your partners in a
new relation you want to feel that type
of like oh for energy
that's super important because you could
go get a deal and if they're not excited
about it and they don't really give a
[ __ ] like
you're it's different yeah when the
people are stoked
makes you stoked and they're doing the
their best and you're doing it gives you
more motivation to go out there and do
your best so touch Keith touch my eye oh
it's [ __ ] over you're about to turn
into [ __ ] incredible hitch
where you had the [ __ ] ski mask on
and I saw the moment where you did it I
just went blood red sickler was saying
that happened to him too we just did a
whole shoot we're sickler by the way
yeah that was awesome big shout out to
Ryan sickler and the Honeydew one of my
favorite flavors from the dopest we went
and did a whole brand shoe before the
[ __ ] Venice Vlog that day yeah that
day
yeah I feel like we've been I don't know
I can't believe we've been here this
many weeks consistently it's insane to
me 85 weeks
yeah
it's gonna be right at almost episode
100 where we like start season three and
move into the new set that's crazy if
it's episode 100 I'd be [ __ ] sick
it's crazy every week this [ __ ] has been
going quick guys life is different with
the podcast it really is like behind us
different
it's fun to go through all these levels
with you guys and like experience this
[ __ ] in real time because every win is
just a big win for the community
everybody on YouTube and Instagram and
all subscribers like
I've seen names in there from like the
first couple episodes are still there
of course it's weird it's wild and
you're gonna start seeing us pop up on
other shows like we're talking about the
Joey Dia [ __ ] hopefully and that is just
something that's in the works but now we
got to go get some we gotta double
triple the size of this community with
similar people out there that could tap
into the [ __ ] yeah that's really all
it's about guys once people start
watching the show they go yeah I'd hang
out with these guys and that's what
makes me a fan I'm like I would like to
hang out with that fool how how many
times I go I love that phone would love
to smoke
that's my thing I would like to hang out
with you because if you're like
have you seen the
Netflix thing the most hated man on the
internet
no there's this Netflix thing about the
revenge porn guy this is uh most hated
man in the internet
he was like hacking people's emails
and putting them on the site and not
putting him down not taking him down he
went to prison for it for hacking
people's emails and like putting their
pictures out there anyway
when I first when I when I met my homie
um
my homie baby
his real name
we were talking like what did you do
before early in the Cannabis Community
like so I used to do like throw these
parties I was like a tech guy I threw
out through all these parties and like
help out with flyers and stuff and it's
my homies like one of my best friends
and we just do parties and all this
stuff he's like he's a piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] I don't talk to him I hope he's in
[ __ ] prison but he was my best friend
I'm like what are you talking about he
explained it to me a little bit
it's this documentary I could see my
homie baby in a couple of shots like
a little tiny baby at like 20 years old
like in the documentary yeah you can see
him in there I hit him up like is this
your [ __ ] friend that's what I asked
him and he goes bro
you don't know how many [ __ ] people
have hit me up I'm like is that you
because he told me when I first met like
10 years ago I was like this guy's a
piece of [ __ ] my old friend Hunter yeah
he's a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] and he got
his baby got his Twitter I'm one of our
friends that knows him got his Twitter
hacked he knows probably [ __ ] Hunter
that's what they said I go who the [ __ ]
is that guy
and I just watched the documentary with
Rosie what a piece of [ __ ] damn
wow and baby I mean a lot of people in
the comments like you're friends with
somebody that was doing that like
no my friend is scot-free no FBI
paperwork and I'm like you didn't get in
trouble because bro I didn't do anything
[ __ ] weird
I was throwing parties I didn't know he
was [ __ ] hacking emails why do you
think the FBI didn't even talk to me
what do you mean FBI he goes bro it was
a big thing
and I was a documentary like I didn't
know how massive this [ __ ] was but I
remember my friend told me he was like
yeah I just threw crazy parties man all
over the country
I was just organized and set up parties
I'm like that's cool now that I see it
now I realize when he was like that
guy's a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] when I
because he found out all this [ __ ] like
as it was happening and he's like I
don't even talk to that [ __ ] and
then I see he's going to jail he's like
good [ __ ] him but how crazy I just
watched a full Netflix documentary on
this [ __ ] dude
Jesus it's such a trip man
people are creeps oh that's what I meant
I would never want to hang out with that
guy just before if I did watch a
documentary and I just saw him talk for
five seconds that guy a guy seems like
such a dick like arrogant [ __ ] I like
people that are arrogant
in a nice way when they know they're
[ __ ] awesome but they're not a piece
of [ __ ] like give me a good example
when your goofy ass fat homie just wears
whatever he wants like
I [ __ ] with you like oh I look tight
like I like that arrogance [ __ ]
that's what I mean like I like that
enthusiasm yeah like I like arrogance
when it's like
conflict yeah it's just confidence it's
not more of like you know how sick I am
[ __ ] it your shoes suck that's not what
I mean that's a piece of [ __ ] yeah yeah
but you know what I mean I think the fat
guy that where that's the perfect
example like yeah yeah you know you're
tired you are tight man my boy back I
told you you used to walk around with
the [ __ ]
bike lock around his neck oh yeah what
the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] he had like a
punching like a boxing glove ring he'd
have a [ __ ] we went over this Hatchet
honest [ __ ] through his belt loop or
real just a hatchet and he'd have all
this [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] on it's just
like all right that's you
you ever seen Water World
no it sounds like he dresses like people
from man I just saw one of my other
[ __ ] somebody that we've talked about
on the show a bunch of times when the
gangster's dudes I know you talk to him
right uh I didn't I know I didn't talk
to him I saw him on Tick Tock what do
you mean you can tell me about this man
I didn't I this [ __ ] is like this [ __ ]
is just
a different it's a different world out
here that's all I'm gonna say this video
I couldn't unsee this video like I even
I was showing it to Ariana on the way
into school today it was just this dude
is one of the most gangster's dudes I
knew growing up and it was just this
Tick Tock video of him
uh
doing this wild dance and this crazy ass
wig and this [ __ ] wild ass [ __ ]
outfit and [ __ ] it was just oh you're
just like
wow even gangbangers like they can't do
[ __ ] it's just wild like I would have
never thought you would do something
online it's such a weird 10-year deal it
was like I was just like thinking back
like and the ship was just so
astonishing like how different things
are right now
I like that though it's like yo the
biggest scariest dude ever is like full
this is fun I'm gonna do it literally
that's awesome it is what we're talking
about and it's something about him that
I've always recognized because I always
noticed in his music he would always
sound completely different he'd be over
here sounding like DMX then he'd come
over here and sound like he's from
[ __ ] Florida with this [ __ ] super
slow [ __ ] draw and [ __ ] and then
he'll come over here and like he could
do all these different [ __ ] sounds
but man I'm like
really crossing over in The Tick Tock
heavy
big [ __ ] time I I don't know man this
[ __ ] was [ __ ] crazy are you saying
just because like the contrast like if
you would have told me 10 years ago that
I would see you yeah online exactly
having fun it would be a shot yes I'm
I'm it's it's really a confidence thing
because it's like God knows I don't have
the confidence to do some [ __ ] like that
tomorrow Tick Tock Marcus dancing his
ass off in a wig big ass [ __ ] wig
spandex overalls into
yeah
you know I was thinking
no that wouldn't work this Halloween
it's not gonna work because I'm gonna be
in New York
next Halloween my mom said she's like I
was gonna be Miss Trunchbull I go good
[ __ ] because my thing with Rosie is I
want to be
Mr wormwood Matilda's dad and Rosie's
gonna tell his mom but I was gonna be
able to tell his dad when the Hat got
stuck to his head
but to get somebody to like
like fake paste blonde oh [ __ ] red
scalped with the shitties you could have
maybe a Matilda put that all together
yo I love Halloween I don't dress up at
all it was fun I used to dress up a lot
when I was a kid
um but it was just a mask
yeah slow dress up yeah it was dressed
up it was fun yeah we had [ __ ] snow
so you'd have like jackets and [ __ ] over
your shirt
trick-or-treating in the snow sounds
like [ __ ] yeah you can't even run
freezing you're seeing your breath
Frigidaire in your lungs all that yeah
buy buy a Halloween it's coming down
April said it was she's she's been in
Buffalo this past week uh she's like
it's like 40 degrees right now
yeah yeah no Every Time I Think of the
East Coast I just think of Macaulay
Culkin in Home Alone 2 when he's walking
back home and he sees the family eating
dinner
and he's like oh
the burglars are about to be here I know
what he just runs back to set up booby
chest most unrealistic movie I said this
like 60 times love it
that's how I think of the East Coast
like snow family sitting that's how I
that's how April thinks of it too I like
it's not it's me in my mind it's me
pulled over [ __ ] they're stretching
the car try to ditch the wheel [ __ ]
the homies are turning their backs on me
yo the first seven years of my life I
had the violent flu on Christmas damn
and I had the same hallucinations so
many years in a row
prayers they didn't think you were like
the devil or some [ __ ] I had the same
one no I was just talking about it too
because I was violently sick through New
Year's too
I had the same hallucinations
all the time
violently flew every like the same week
every year
and then
at my Grandma's on New Year's my other
grandmas there's a Christian Slater
movie out there
that comes on on Christmas I mean on New
Year's like at one in the morning
you know what sleep paralysis is right
yeah so like three years in a row was I
awake I know I was awake but I was like
someone was bear hugging me I couldn't
move for like three hours
every new year for three years in a row
and it was this Christian Slater movie I
would sit there I couldn't I'd just be
staring at him and some chick and then
it was like almost like the cut like
like the shapes I could like feel the
shapes of that where I'm coming out the
screen I was so sick every year that
like those years I was just like there's
something about that damn movie that
makes me just start violently spinning I
can't move I start locking up and I can
see everybody asleep on New Year's and I
can't say anything to him
and then that would just stop and I'd
wake somebody up by crying Jesus Christ
so is it sleep paralysis or just
Christian Slater that captivated
you know that's where you're going with
them no no that was the last time no
I've heard of people with that like that
sucked that's yeah I've heard of people
describe it like uh ghostly deathly
horrible experience one time Paul
servino in my dream you know that is
Paul you ever seen Goodfellas yeah
Paulie the the boss oh okay
one time
I had a dream that he was attacking me
and bear hugging me and crushing me like
trying to kill me random and I woke up
in the living room right next to my jaw
Uncle John's house and I lived in the
apartment to apartment that time
I don't know how but this [ __ ]
blanket was like wrapped around me so
tight I could not move and when I got up
it's like someone folded me up and
rolled me and put me on the ground
how it happened I have no that's the
last time I had sleep paralysis
but what maybe that wasn't actually
sleep maybe you were just [ __ ] or
whatever you call it yes that that's the
last time that happened to me yeah
no thank you yo man you guys I've talked
about it before I've been having these
weird dreams again I hope nothing's
wrong I hope nothing happens
but I've been having some weird ass
[ __ ] apocalyptic ass dreams again
like what I don't know the other day I
was a
ugh
I had the fake Alien Invasion dream at
my grandma Grace's house every I've had
it like 50 times there'll be Alien
Invasion going on and these like I'm on
the hill just looking at ships come in
with like blasting things
and then they're flying and they start
like getting staticky and they're just
drones
and then they go back to being a
spaceship oh Jesus Christ like them
flicking Spider-Man that Spider-Man was
like oh attack oh they're just drones
what
that's why my dream like [ __ ] four
years in I don't know oh it's the same
dream
that only comes around
whenever it wants to is it all around
throughout the year yeah
um
it's always the same [ __ ] same exact
dream same exact spot same sky
and then there's always a mass shooting
in Vape I'm always I gotta stop bleep
that there's always a place in Vegas I
have the reoccurring dream I told you
about
but
I don't know I hear like seven eight
years I got a recurring dream that I'm
running in Vegas through like the halls
and like
there's like gunfire people screaming
and all this stuff right
so I have these weird dreams but the
other night I had this the weirdest one
I always have dreams where I look up and
I can see other like planets or whatever
but this one like
I woke up I'm scared
that like oh man this is real this sucks
not like am I scared of my life it's
always like
I finally doing okay
of course that's how I always feel like
mom bro you can dismals to a little kid
just poor by myself like um
dream the other day that I was standing
I don't remember where I was I look up
and I see the moon and then I saw like
another Moon moving right by it and
everybody in the Street's looking up
like what the [ __ ]
and then I look up and there's like
seven
Balls of Fire moving across the
sky
but they're all moons just look like on
fire
and they're all moving and I run inside
to get Rosy and when I go with that
everyone I know is in this house
I grab right look out and they're just
like
sci-fi
weird stuff going on like spaceships and
helicopters and UFOs and just weird [ __ ]
this one was different definitely the
scary way scary way yeah this one I did
not like
I never like any of them are you not
realizing you're dreaming in any of
these
no they're always real my room dreams
are so realistic but there's no element
you realize I don't I don't have that no
more or I told you when I used to do it
anytime like oh I'm Dreaming let me just
jump off this wall into this guy
when I started dating Rosie went away I
can't control him anymore it sucks
it was weird like I could I remember
when they were moving leaving I remember
when they were going away it was like a
little less control every couple weeks
and then just one day stop and I forgot
about it like in Peter Pan like
Neverland I I forgot that I could do
that when I was a kid I used to go what
am I going to do tonight all right all
right try to fall asleep but me Rosie
first started dating we would always
because I told her about my dream she's
like what and then one time we had the
same dream and we lost our [ __ ] like wow
we used to every night like what are we
doing tonight all right what are we
doing what are you doing what are you
doing all right start thinking about
this try falsely and we would just try
to do it all the time all the time dude
then one night it just clicked perfect
we woke up we always say like what did
you dream about and she said like oh
[ __ ]
shock is like
we should do it all the time what
happened I don't know
we stopped we just stopped doing it my
dreams aren't fun forgot about it yeah
my shoes aren't fun anymore they suck
now
I don't know I never remember my dreams
that sucks I remember people you know
they say you can't make up a face in
your dream yes you can totally 100 it's
a composite of people you might have
seen shut up no AI going down [ __ ] yeah
no I had a dream and I was in the
seventh grade I was in the math class
when I got a student of the year stuff
Mr Mondo that guy I was sitting in my I
was in the second row over when that kid
tried to stab me and tell you he tried
to stab me in class
he was talking [ __ ] to me I said
something to him and I don't know what
kind of cat light reflexes I have I was
looking this way and I felt something I
just went like this
this fool from behind tried to stab me
in the neck with a pencil he went it
went into my face like that much and I
stopped it I just started bleeding and I
was just like
[ __ ] out of him and it just ended there
damn it was the weirdest thing
oh if I forgot it was out seventh grade
yeah anyways I think I was in class
see my brain it just went off on a
tangent
that class is the only reason I brought
that up damn it so I was in the center
yeah that was a math class that's that's
the one that's back when I used to have
the Vivid ass dreams anyway I had a
dream of this chick this girl I've never
seen before
she was from France
or a foreign country I remember the FR
and I'm like it has to be friends
there's not a lot of FR countries or I
mean I was a kid
and I was like that's so weird I woke up
I remember what she looked like remember
she looked like that was the weirdest
dream I like some Wonder Years like wow
is that the girl I'll marry one day how
weird like you're gonna be like Wonder
Years like what's is this significant
why did I have a dream I go to school
and
it's wild when I see things like
I already knew that was gonna happen
that is odd
the second we sit down he starts
introducing some girl and it's the girl
for my [ __ ] dream dead on same face
same ponytail everything I'm looking at
she walks and I'm like
oh my God I got light-headed like what
the [ __ ]
like this is the crazy that was like the
third time my dreams have come real as a
kid so I was like
all right so it's a real one all right
all right let's go excuse for Mexico
didn't speak English she spoke Spanish
it wasn't I mean but it was the same
girl I couldn't talk to her something
strange
and then she went into the English
Spanish classes that was it
and I I know she went to my high school
and everything I I mean I don't remember
her name now but I remember her and then
she went to Merced and then she left but
Rand and I had a dream about this girl
that randomly moved and then the second
I sat down
she walked in they go shut the [ __ ] up
and then Mr we have a new student today
oh shut the [ __ ] up and I never talked
to her anyway spoke Spanish so I
couldn't talk to her even she spoke
French I couldn't talk to her
but in my dreams spoke English right so
anyway I remember that that was crazy as
hell
oh I've had a bunch of dreams that come
true we've talked about them before
um but so like two of them I feel like
save my damn life did we I thought we
talked about it we're uh
that due to the rainbow room I told you
about it where I had a dream about that
guy right and he was like a [ __ ] gang
banger crazy [ __ ]
yeah dude they're just weird but I've
been having these dreams that's why I
don't like these
Skye
alien explosion
stuff I don't like it dude there's been
so much UFO talk and it's been
I don't know it's almost like normalized
it is 100 when I see a UFO thing I
scroll past because I go bro I've been
seeing a small life you're just starting
to look at it I'm bored of it how about
OG can come on here and literally talk
about anything and nobody bats tonight
anything he says like he literally could
say anything everybody's like he's
talking about his homie that was so lost
or scared he's like
it's not uh we just look up because he
he owes you like try to catch him on the
camera one time I was like whoa that's
crazy because I got I told you I got a
couple on the picture but I was so
scared
I didn't like transfer them like nah you
can just leave those in the dust erase
them done that phone traded in an ATT
anyway I'm done but um
yeah I don't know I don't know I've been
having some really weird dreams lately I
don't like it
I hope everything's okay
yeah yeah
Jesus Christ let's try to [ __ ] be
positive is Rosie got the murder
mysteries going late night and [ __ ]
anything apocalyptic going down on the
TV I've had these dreams for like 10
years yeah yeah I've been having the
Independence Day style not even aliens I
just have weird dreams I don't like it
because I don't like it because when my
dreams come true I'm like come on man
don't be giving me end of world dreams
[ __ ]
like this is not what I want to look at
man
I'm wrong let's just say I hope I'm
[ __ ] oh nothing I got [ __ ] to do that
tomorrow yeah
we could be having like sick ass VR
style dreams here a cool ass [ __ ] like
come on yeah I don't know I've been
having random ass dreams lately dude
it's just the weirdest I don't know
what's been going on
but two nights ago I didn't know I was
in the dream
and I still you know what's crazy is I
have my conscience in my dream still so
I can't do anything crazy like punch a
perk that doesn't work
never thought about that I always feel
bad yeah I want to hit these birds
that's I've never even really thought
about that having your conscience having
your conscience within your it's always
their life it's always yeah I told
reason first started dating her um I had
a dream that this girl was hitting on me
and I woke up like get away from me and
I was like what I still have a
conscience in my dream all guilty and
[ __ ] yeah it was so weird
yeah so I two nights ago I did some old
lady was walking up to me and I was in
the middle of like
EA Street slash New York Street and I
could see lights like Vegas and I was on
a hill next to the ocean like it's I've
been going to the same like land dream
for like 20 times in a row now sounds
like black mirror so much that I know my
way to my own house and my dream Marty
damn
that's some black mirrors I don't like I
don't like it Hollywood Boulevard right
where Wokcano is is in my dream too that
little piece is right on the top of the
African dreams like this can we confirm
this in the comments please because I've
never I don't go back and [ __ ] have a
map or anything like an under like
similarly it makes me feel sick
like like it makes me feel nauseous like
oh like where is this place it makes me
feel like why do I keep going to the
same place I can draw for you
I know exactly what it looks like but
I'm only on one road on the side of the
cliff it goes into the tunnel and
there's a bridge and until and then the
bottom is a hotel I take the elevator
down this is cool I don't like it weird
stuff always happens oh
I have dreams about editing videos and
[ __ ] I edit my [ __ ] like dreams I
remember if I'm up late I know I gotta
get it done I'll literally edit my
[ __ ] dreams and they're stressful oh
my
so you're editing in your dreams or
you're editing the dream no there's a
I'm physically in Final Cut Pro in my
dream like editing a video thinking
about I know I got to get up and get
this done yeah oh yeah yeah yeah I do
stuff like that where I'm just doing the
stuff I have to do when I get up I hate
that yeah as you know you're busy yeah
it's like not a very deep sleep
yeah yeah dude I've been going to the
same place I don't like it um
I could see where the hill is and part
of the street
turns into it's so odd dude like it's
it's streets that I've seen or streets
I've been all pushed into one
and then the cleat the cliff on the left
on the right side
everything and it's just scut it makes
me sick like it makes me feel like I
don't like this place
keep having this weird dream about this
place and every time I'm there I'm stuck
and I can't get home
like I know I don't live there but I
have a house in this place but you want
to be I want to be back and I could
never get to Rosie that's my dream
it's like where is she still home I
can't get to her she can't chill nowhere
I am I'm mostly
it's always such a weird dream I've cut
to 10 years from now this is like the
plot of your hit [ __ ] movie
how crazy would that be
uh
woke up in the middle of night last
night
Marty that you say that
um
September 22nd
wrote down my oh movie idea right there
my movie idea that I went
I can see this already being made I know
the cuts I was in my dead sleep woke up
started writing this I don't know what
hit me and I just went
oh my God I got the movie in my head I
got like and it's not even a comedy it's
a scary movie but I got a good one
enough to make you Ponder for days
it hit me bro hmm
I got it
you say that I just wrote it down
hopefully in like eight years you'll be
like yo this is the episode damn
straight up that right there I got it
like I
when I thought of the whole thing I'm
half asleep I'm like right I'm typing
I'm typing I know when I'm tired when
this stuff's misspelled yeah and I'm
just typing and then I woke up and read
and go oh my God
my god this is my [ __ ]
so hopefully hopefully one day yeah yes
but this place uh
my dream I don't know I could see I
could show you it uh you know those maps
for kids on the floor and they have the
city it's one of those oh no it's one of
those places if it was 3D and straight
up okay it's not a big place
it's a GTA map essentially it is a small
place that I've only been in
if it's this big I'm only coming up on
the c-cliff right here my house is over
here here's the trees here's the place
of that old lady with the with the hotel
and the Vegas strips here in the middle
me and Rosie live in a high-rise right
here
and then over here is the hotel where I
got stuck in the bottom come down here
all the way in the back is a tunnel
where everyone's coming in and
underneath is like a bridge and that's
the entrance of the dream are the drones
your main antagonist like what's
stressing you out so bad in there like
the side like what I just don't like the
place like I can't get back
typing to texter and every number is
wrong oh
I'm trying to run and I'm in water I'm
trying to get in the car can't get the
keys I'm trying to run it and like
[ __ ] up everything I'm just I'm doing
this
oh no my whole dream like I can't get
anywhere that's how it's always man
in this place I can't get back that's my
thing because I know where I'm at and I
know I don't belong there that's my
thing every time like I don't live here
I keep trying to get back but
The Invasion Dream It's push tree's
house I've been going back to lately
it's weird no no sorry my grandma
Grace's house but I have the dream where
I'm like fighting off I have the
recurring dreams where I am getting
like door kicked in by like 12 random
dudes and I'm blasting people through
the window I hate it oh and it's always
push tree's house the last time I lived
there I thought someone was gonna kicked
my door well someone's trying to [ __ ]
rob me and kick my door in so I moved
allegedly
so I had that dream a lot yeah well I
mean that makes sense that's some
[ __ ] I had it first I had it for a
while
I hate it but it always goes right back
to that place even though it's been like
eight years
still in there I hate it
I don't know what to say man the dude
that I was just the dude I was talking
about with that Tick Tock video I
remember him telling me a story about
his homeboy coming to the door and like
going to slap him up dude sticks gun and
slams the door he's got the door slammed
on his hand did you just [ __ ]
shooting off in his house and [ __ ]
[ __ ] slamming his hand on the door
like
just your boy
you're like crazy [ __ ] like that in real
life I hate it like that [ __ ] happens
so yeah
yeah you know what it is
it's my environment too I notice when
I'm when I see horrible things I have
really bad dreams I got stuck on a
Twitter thread the other day I don't
like seeing people get hurt unjustly and
I saw like 30 videos in a row
and what you said like homies what's up
fool turns around bomb Oh My on camera
ring camera like bro what
like you could tell they're homies
I saw horrible one in a gas station the
other day where the dude like wasn't
even interested in robbing the gas
station at all he just had the deer just
hopped over the counter and not even
really caring knowing he's going to kill
this dude the dude's thinking he's like
just robbing the place like just gets
behind him and just like ah like just
like evil pure English the world star
Twitter I mean it's just so normal now
you're not meant to see that [ __ ] like I
I I've been I saw like pnb rock video
we're not meant to see that horrible the
buffalo video we're not meant to be
watching this
that was so sad bro yeah oh oh yeah in
fact you can see your homie on camera is
like dude don't why'd you record that
that's sad like the fools on the floor
died you're just recording him like
[ __ ] he could see you he could see you
right there holding your phone help me
might be the last thing he thinks about
it's horrible horrible dude and there's
like
that's like that's like one of a hundred
different videos I've seen I'm just
people don't give a [ __ ] you don't care
about people at all man
it was Merck people would for nothing
and the thing that I see
on a lot of these videos like gang maker
fools like getting shot and shooting
each other all of them baller cars all
of them dressed nice like bro go live
your life
like damn you died wearing a three
thousand dollar outfit
good good job like why don't you just
you know go home that's the craziest
thing it's like you guys would probably
be homies that's what bugs me you guys
are probably friends say one thing about
hey I watched I should do that [ __ ] was
[ __ ] awesome yeah totally it's crazy
it's you see the video about the
ex-boyfriend dude trying to get in his
girlfriend's house don't be like bro
that was crazy
what an idiot that situation is just
like idiot bro come on I mean you dated
her you know her dad yeah and you know
that he's not gonna put up with it and
why would you I saw it's like
I'd be so sad if that was my kid going
in the door but also like what are you
doing that really makes you just like
you really do need a Nerf gun around the
house though because you really do need
a Nerf gun I love that because otherwise
now you just got this psycho uh you know
crystal candy had coming through your
door and you got to go hand to hand or
whatever you got in the house you can't
knock a crackhead or a crystal meth head
out
yeah you just have to beat them to death
or something you're not gonna knock them
out no you gotta hit him with the lock
them in the fridge yeah like a bull and
Bam
methods hate the cold methods aren't are
they Invincible to like like mace and
stuff taser well tasers yes because like
mace Mason the taser in combination with
each other is what I'm coming with
this your best hope I mean I'm going
mace then I'm tasing you up then I'm
coming knees and elbows then we're going
oh my first thing this thing is like if
they're trying to hurt me it's all ready
to go
but I feel bad I don't really hurt of
course so it's like we're talking about
this psycho bursting and you help
somebody hard but put my head hand
behind their or behind their head
so I didn't hurt them you know what I
mean like I'm not trying to crack your
head but I want you to feel the force of
like this is what could happen to you
so like a crackhead if they're not if
they're just trying to like rob me like
I'll dip somebody but I'm not trying to
like
didn't but if they're trying to hurt me
like get ready for the pedigree Triple H
I'm gonna dip you on top of your head
and I hope your head pops like I'm not
trying to kill somebody I hope you just
start leaking you don't want to move
like I hope you just sit there like oh I
should have said like because I don't
want to hurt you know I mean I really
want to hurt somebody but like I told
like I've said before someone's really
trying to hurt me
um it's bad
you gotta I mean it's just you gotta I
think it's gonna be so bad dude I'm
talking about like in a fight like bro
that's not fair
like as if I win
you're gonna wake up horrible I'ma break
your legs for sure that's one thing if
someone's trying to kill me I'm gonna
I'm gonna break the leg I feel bad but
I'm definitely gonna hold it straight
and like kick that knee straight in so
when they wake up
that's what they wake up to and always
remember when you walk with a limp it's
because you try to rob that dude in the
alley and you punched him it's not a
good Fellas quote yeah no because yeah
you'll never be the same
180 000 surgery good luck with that yeah
I mean like that's what I'm gonna do
forever I'm thinking about this
financially full circle for you imagine
therapy oh God just take the lug off oh
yeah at that point just take my leg off
bro or the arm
just just
snap it Hoover yeah it's not too bad you
just really put your foot here pop it I
will break someone's [ __ ] arm off if
I have to and it's so sad I feel
disgusting even saying it
but in certain sections when you have
kids you think about it all the time in
certain situations yeah yeah like I said
before I call dig through your through
your chest like
I will try my best
um I just saw this I forget what it was
called the most amazing it wasn't the
most amazing movie this craziness movie
where like
all right I'm gonna give you the plot of
this movie I don't even know the name of
it but it's like all right Truman Show
there's a no I'm kidding there's a witch
okay there's a witch I don't know where
the witch the witchery started
no okay you can the only the only way
that the witch passes the witchery on
you can only pass it on to one person in
your witch life is by like slicing them
and spitting blood on them okay this
movie's random
oh okay okay but then what but then now
that you're witched now that you got
your Immortal witch life you gotta start
consuming people to keep that keep your
life going but the way they do it is
they like just rip apart your body and
take out the insides and then put it in
their insides now I'm filled with your
insides
everybody have you already said that
[ __ ] I wish I could remember the name of
this movie it was horrible I see a
movie's got to be that outlandish for me
to get into it I need like outlandish
grues some wild [ __ ] for me to pay
attention I can't do any of that yeah
that'll keep me around for the movie if
you're doing crazy [ __ ] like that [ __ ]
me too much like uh
ah man what's the name of that [ __ ]
oh God it sounds what's the name of the
movie where they know on their 27th
birthday they gotta jump off the cliff
that was horrible dumb mid-summer yes
see that I'm for I'll go for a weird
movie like that oh thank you the second
they were just killing people
unjustly I was out no I'm good I can't I
like your weirdness though I like your
weirdness because I can't follow just a
regular movie without outlandish crazy
[ __ ] going on I can't well it bugs me so
[ __ ] yeah
all day I'm still thinking about
Starship Troopers when he made the fool
put his hand on it put the knife through
his hand because he [ __ ] up that was
in 1995 and I'm still thinking about it
Gary Busey son they make Gary PC's son
put his hand and they stabbed through it
that was some [ __ ]
I don't know about those oh so [ __ ]
bad
but when I watch Goodfellas and they
shot Joe passion and I go okay he was a
bad guy
even since I was a kid I'm like I can't
watch somebody just get killed for
nothing I can't that's when I got on
that thread the other day I'm like this
is the worst thing I've ever seen in my
life oh people who are ruthless I hate
everyone I don't want anybody around me
I hate everybody that's how I felt like
yeah I don't want to say I feel that way
but it's like it was disgusting dude oh
people do that [ __ ] for nothing yeah
they bug me you gotta you gotta you
gotta stay paranoid out here yeah you
really do it's just though you just
gotta kind of be your Baseline I unlock
my door looking behind me because those
keys I can't hear anybody walking up on
me I unlock my door like this every
[ __ ] time no in my secure ass
building I don't trust anyone I think
about getting Richard I try and every
time I get out of the car
really I do I don't even like admit that
cause I don't like even thinking about
it but like yeah I do
oh hell no man I really yeah a survey
[ __ ] yeah
eyeball [ __ ] every time when I pull up
and get out big time I live in these
apartment buildings bro so it's so much
more stressful on me I have to look
through cars and [ __ ] when I'm walking
out
I don't trust anybody every elevator I
wait one second
and I go low and peak in case the
motherfucker's ready to take my head off
or something
I hate it I [ __ ] hate it I've been
doing my whole life because those ruined
me and they mean so but then again
I would have been dead if I turned
around that fool shot me in the face
yeah so me being very cautious I think
it was just a pencil I don't think it
would kill me but he definitely would
have [ __ ] me up but he he got me right
in my face that's probably with his
little scars from that's wildly
aggressive to be doing yeah and there
was like lead the lead was in my head I
had to pull it out I was pissed dude
I was like oddly like
this kid's psychology
he's getting like a week later he was
gone from the school damn weird ass
Mexican kid dude weird as [ __ ]
so I'm glad
but I think that's what it is like like
those Instinct I mean I would have
[ __ ] been dead whatever trying to
shoot me in the bed like I would have
been dead already
so it's like whatever you said that on
the adventure Channel you were like
you're like well you're driving through
Merced you're like there's the place
where the kid chopped me with the
homemade uh around the adventure Channel
I forgot it was driving through every
time I passed that place I think about
it like wow and my whole life I'm like
someone's gonna try so I'm gonna get
shot in the back of the head that's not
gonna die or said I always thought that
like dancing was gonna kill me in there
I don't even think it was me it's gonna
be a mistake I already know what's gonna
happen and literally that but thank God
that it was a homemade one they didn't
know what the [ __ ] they were doing I
mean they knew what they were doing but
it just didn't
didn't pan out you know and I won't say
it the names but
I know exactly what that kid looks like
I somebody did send me an article a
while back
and I'm pretty sure it's the same kid
but he got caught for a murder
um pretty sure it's the same [ __ ] kid
Jesus Christ you know like 18 when they
caught him and I told you it was like 11
10 year old 12 year old kid that shot me
I'm like yo that's the [ __ ] kid that
tried to shoot me
so he's in prison
that's good yeah that's great like
that's a menace to society bro like what
are you doing you [ __ ] idiot is there
fixing that kid generally like I mean
well it's not his fault I know he's a
kid he's the older dude the dude's
driving him should be in prison not the
child
you're very influenced as a kid
if your parents aren't home and these
other fools just went and bought you
lunch and like you get to wear the
clothes they're wearing like you feel
like the older kid hey Fogo shoot this
kid like you're gonna do it to feel down
or you're not going to be down anymore
it's a vicious cycle and it's not just
us it's all over the world so it's not
like it's a psychological human thing
yeah it's not just a gang thing that's
[ __ ] Humanity's always done use the
little kids it don't matter
so yeah for sure is I think it's the
same bit I I don't know I'm like 90 sure
it's the same same kid different hair
tattoos but I know it's the same [ __ ]
face you're like a little boy like a
little how long how many moments did you
see him for
four seconds popped me and I went
I got my
troll back and I turned around like who
the [ __ ] and I saw the car and I saw his
face it's like yo no way he's a little
[ __ ] kid so
what are we talking about stay paranoid
yeah that's what we're talking about
stay paranoid out there
people are creeps people are weird
all right so
we're pretty good into this video now we
just started rambling
I just want to State this we went into
this episode with no notes whatsoever
negative notes
we're doing okay we're doing okay you
know what I mean it's pretty good we're
at two hours yeah
all right we've been here for way longer
than I thought we would be
um
got the meet and greet tomorrow yeah
they're super stoked
this thing's coming out just in like two
days three days this episode yep and
then we got next after this it was Chevy
Woods Jaleel and then we're gonna wait
talk about more guests after that
um hopefully October will be a Joey Diaz
episode but it was weird if you're not
there it'd be kind of odd
you know what I do no it's gonna be
we'll figure yes that's something that
just the internet the whole Community
but you know what I mean
yeah I mean [ __ ] well he'll he'll end up
next time he comes out that well we
don't you know what I mean we'll see
what happens yeah for sure but it's just
like
so like it was weird
not in our studio huh what was it like
we're in Wayne's base bit but we're not
that's how I'm gonna feel it yeah
um
all right let me get out of here Max I
know this would be a big edit
yeah thanks guys yeah yeah I've edit my
sleep apparently you edit this one in
your sleep
we'll see we'll see get a cam on it as
soon as he gets good but I can't we take
this night shift you're gonna be up
anyway right I've started them doing
that he's got the iMac going I got him
in all kinds of [ __ ] let's see he's been
doing his videos I got him [ __ ]
tagging [ __ ] up with [ __ ] paint and
[ __ ] now we're doing that oh my
signature's so bad for tomorrow we got
to get you one we got to make your
signature sucks I apologize every time I
sign something every time it could be
it's just got to be a nice simple YOLO
y-o-l-a
you do the same way every time nice and
easy oh my God I don't even know my own
signature my signature do you spell out
yeah when I sign my own name
scribbles it just scribbles yeah I mean
it's the same kind of scribbles but it's
not real yeah I know what it looks like
looks the same but it's anyway
I signed my name in print I know have a
dope ass day you write it like as if
it's on like the lined paper with like
100
that's exactly how I write it because
that's how I wrote my whole life I went
from the thick lines to the little lines
yeah no we gotta make it like like a
little logo like a tag real easy one one
I was thinking about a Stamper but it's
just such a lazy thing to do but it
would look nice yeah it would look nice
you just got to get a cool marker you
got to get the right marker that'll make
it fun or get a shitty logo a shitty
signature as a Stamper but look at this
[ __ ] kind of hard but not Stanford's
just too lazy you have to sign [ __ ]
um so if you come tomorrow I'm sorry for
your I've ruined so many shirts but not
ruined like they're always happy but
it's like
I sign the back of it so I'll [ __ ] up
the front all the time so you ever see
somebody with a pushed tree shirt
there's a child's hand right against
mine for sure I found 40 of these have a
dope ass day oh it looks so bad dude
I've said so many of these shoes
um all right let's get out of here man
we gotta he's got a long drive thank you
guys thank you for the 300K per episode
we're proud of this [ __ ] and we just hit
200 000. let's go
let's go oh sweet
oh it's close yeah we said 200 000
subscribers on YouTube thank you very
much Spotify listens
way up
way up thank you guys also shout out to
Spotify for uh putting our advertisers
out there pushing the show near
continued support
thank you very much appreciate you so if
you're in a drive put on Spotify still
video but if you're at home chilling
well anyway you can watch doesn't matter
we have a Spotify video so it doesn't
matter YouTube or Spotify either way
leave a like comment review whatever you
want to do we appreciate it guys I am
oddly high for smoking that little
amount of weed
you've been fasting yeah I have been I
haven't taken been taking dabs today
either I've been doing [ __ ]
oh well I've really got an eye at all
okay maybe that's what just happened no
all right I'm looking forward to
sampling these new dopest products and
seeing what that's all about this is all
groundbreaking Innovative pioneering you
guys are doing here to be scary they're
strong I have a feeling like people
don't realize what's gonna happen
it's a hash careful yeah everybody's
already really happy with what oh yeah
there like yeah
we're gonna do something doing
yourselves with this a lot coming out
man I'm so stoked
um yeah so yeah support thank you guys
so much for supporting everything push
trees dope as usual
thank you thank you guys the
dopashop.com I'm high yeah I don't feel
my spaciness coming in we have some
signal artwork on the way also by the
way that's so [ __ ] sick can't wait
for you guys to see it a part of me
wants to hold it for season three but
it's like don't do it just as soon as
you got it it is so [ __ ] cool that
looks like a damn liquor store or like
the side of a of a corporation
windy it like it looks like
Ben and Jerry's that's how I imagined it
there was a Ben and Jerry's like it's
so [ __ ] cool
those are like the big heads from the
NFL toys from exactly we were kids
that's what they look like oh my God we
look [ __ ] awesome like cartoon
versions of us for real YouTube Banner
my boy that does all like Snoop Dogg's
illustrations and [ __ ] hooked it up yeah
it's actually
30 times better I thought it could ever
be um like I didn't know what he was
doing and just like
it almost has like a Martin Vibe our
words it has like this yeah it looks
like Martin from the beginning
yeah it's sick love it I'm so excited I
love stepping outside of myself when I'm
so used to like doing the brand design
for something that's a difficult video
getting somebody with different skill
set involved completely different look
yeah hell yeah hell yeah well [ __ ] yeah
guys thank you for being here appreciate
I hope it's not age restricted we can
talk about too much crazy stuff today
we'll see I don't remember either past
couple episodes been good we've been
having to bleep a little but the bleeps
are [ __ ] funny so it's okay but we
also demonetize ourselves yeah oh we
told the fans yeah we took all we don't
get paid on any episodes anymore we took
all of it off
it sucks but we were getting age
restricted every two seconds and as soon
as we stopped trying to get paid for the
episode
they let us go
so we're just playing this game now yeah
so now we're doing this of
that's cool but it's okay we'll work
here for free man
just let us we're trying okay we're
trying to make it work
here we are guys thank you so much for
being here Marty got anything else thank
you guys I love this shirt I appreciate
our whole community and all the way it's
trickling down and how nice everybody is
and everybody that deals with us notices
wow you guys really got the nicest fans
out there every time it's like that's
the best I love that people do people
always say that like there was nothing
negative on the comments the guests the
everybody people that we work with in
the offices and stuff like everybody
notices it the guests for sure yeah
especially when the guests usually get
some some [ __ ] talk they're like dude
nobody was talking [ __ ] like I know what
was Adam 22 he's like nobody was being
rude in the comedy like yeah they're
astonished he's like I went in there
just a lab and I'm like no no people are
nice yeah we've I've blocked like 30
people over the course of a year and a
half great that's not a lot of people
like that was rude yeah it doesn't take
much to get the second you're rude
that's it takes one
time yeah you're gonna get one I was
telling us to my kid like and 25 people
you're gonna have one somebody who's
gonna like suck be a rude person for
sure just roll with it you get up to 200
000 to consider how nice and supportive
this community is just a blessing yeah
stoked thank you guys and thank you for
always being here and being in the live
chat and commenting and everything thank
you guys so much also the bombs will be
dropping very soon but uh not by the
time this episode's out for the next
episode yeah we're getting all the
photos done they're getting everything
situated with the website and then
things will be live and various colors
and sizes they're so sick you're gonna
it's gonna I'm so excited for it like
it's so high quality I'm
they're really on it I can tell yeah I'm
excited I'm excited for people just to
send us the pictures and videos using it
uh
I'm stuck I'm excited let's go um all
right that was it thank you guys thank
you guys thank you so much for being
here this has been the dope usual
podcast this has been another episode
we're gonna talk about life drugs
problems accomplishments and everything
in between somehow
I had to burp for the last like three
seconds or the last three sentences
didn't Urban still spoke I'm a beat
boxer I remember Tonight Show I'm a beat
boxer now that's it I'm officially Biz
Markie I've been beatboxing that's me
now you're gonna do breakdowns on top of
the table and shouldn't break the
Shadows too bro it's not as dirty as you
think it is I mean well no
yeah yeah it is it is I'll still break
it
I would never get on this table guys
thank you so much for watching
um thank you appreciate it I am
completely [ __ ] off track
that little bit we got me all right here
we go thank you so much for watching
leave a like notification bell all that
stuff if you're on YouTube if you're on
Spotify thank you for being here drop uh
that
thumb I don't think they do that so uh
what are they doing positive feedback
positive feedback thank you guys so much
comments hopefully coming soon yeah
we're asking for that we're asking for
all that I'm trying to get comments on
Spotify for us I did live trying man I'm
trying to get live implemented
spotify's working with us like they're
actually helping so thank you once again
to Spotify we appreciate you guys thank
you for being here thank you for
supporting for being awesome being
stoked I'm gonna go home and go watch an
episode of that show peaky blinders with
Rosie because I just got started it and
I got stuck on it damn it they caught me
let me go I'm watching documentary is
there really one should be if there's
not oh we should make it yeah and it's
just us voice overing Brett Favre's
Parts well you know
I am an [ __ ] that guy Thomas no his
arms better accuracy is better I should
have signed those [ __ ] I should have
signed that jacket for him that's what
he's gonna say to me
could happen as I'm like sure
Park this close
and then he's gonna go don't worry I'm
gonna go thanks Brett Favre
I was saying before I was gonna be a
valet driver hmm because he owns a valet
service
I have no idea I was just going into the
future
of Brett Favre being a piece of [ __ ] and
it broke my heart and now I don't care
about him anymore
at least we can rest while knowing that
he is an actual piece of [ __ ] of all
this alleged information is true it
wasn't just you
I hope this episode comes to bite me in
the ass because it was all untrue I hope
you know bro I hope so Brett Favre we
hold big forever big favery
f-a-v-r-e dumbest spelling ever guys
thank you so much for being here this
has been this has been ESPN with Stephen
A Smith talking [ __ ] guys thank you so
much for being here dude I don't know
enough about sports talk about sports
but I do like them
Brett fire I loved him start damn I just
can't even get away from the subject
we're about to be I've been trying to
end this I'm sorry
he's the drones and the dreams that's
symbolic it's just a face it is a face
that's gonna appear like Mufasa
The Lion King I came to get your welfare
money
I'm sorry I ruined y'all's Black Panther
Party that's how I imagined him talking
except I'm sorry I it mess with all your
way I feel money
foreign
[ __ ] him guys thank you so much for
being here we appreciate you have a dope
ass day y'all I wouldn't I would have
went for 31 more minutes bro 30 more
minutes I would have just talked
[ __ ] you know I'll always be true to you
Mary [ __ ] him
[Music]